Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich möchte ja auch gern mal so richtig befördert werden.
Haben musst aber erstmal so richtig verkacken.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 206.
18168 das wird fordert 68250 September 2018.
Ein schöner Donnerstag am Donnerstag geht er die Welt unter habe ich meinen an tollen Buch gelesen und dieses Gefühl beschleicht mich eigentlich auch jede Woche unten ja Linus ist nicht da und deswegen.
Ist der Thomas mal wieder dabei hatte Thomas live zugeschaltet aus dem schönen Wien nehme ich an.
Ja genau.
Wo bist du jetzt genau da bist du ja viel am wuseln das haben wir ja auch immer mal wieder hier.
Thematisiert und ja ich denke nicht der schlechteste Zeitpunkt für Linus kleine Auszeit zu machen zumal ja jetzt auch soviel sowohl Österreich passiert ist als auch auf
europäischer Ebene 2 ganz gut ist dass wir hier vielleicht mal ein red Etap gleich machen.
Ja es gibt richtig viel zu besprechen also in Österreich gibt's ein paar Sachen die hoffentlich lesen Sie bisschen lustig sind eigentlich sind sie traurig
und Österreich hat ja auch die Ratspräsidentschaft dadurch sind wir dieses Halbjahr auch recht involviert bei den ganzen raus lichkeiten die noch bis Jahresende dort verhandelt werden.
Gut.
Aber wir fangen erstmal an mit Feedback jetzt hatten wir ja letzte Woche und diese Woche natürlich auch wieder so ein wenig auch die AFD wieder im Nacken.
Unter anderem griffen wir noch mal den Tweet von dem AFD trollhan Brandner auf.
Und Linus hat sich dann wieder zu der Formulierung verstiegen habe ja ein foto mit einer Machete gepostet ich erinnere mich dass wir das Ding irgendwie schon mal geklärt haben dass das natürlich keine Machete ist und so haben Acorn und andere Leute uns noch mal darauf hingewiesen
das ist keine Machete ist sondern eine hippe ja.
Ja ich ich ich finde es ganz spannend ich habe jetzt mir nicht dieses Video von dem afdd angeschaut
ja ich habe mit den österreichischen Rechts populi tickern genügend zu tun aber ich habe jetzt nur irgendwie den Wikipedia-Artikel zu hippe gesehen und das könnte auch eine sigra sein.
Nee ich bin wieder sehr sicher ich schicke dir noch mal das Foto da ist also ganz typisch sowohl die Krümmung passend als auf dieser extra kleine Steg Angriff also.
Wir bleiben jetzt bei Hüppe nicht weitere Konfusion.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Gerät was doch irgendwie den dem europäischen Kulturraum zuzuordnen ist
ja aber halt sehr lange zurück geht also ein Römisches Reich ist das sind wahrscheinlich auch so Traditionen auf die sich die AFD da wahrscheinlich bewusst Berufen will.
Ja den fällt auf jeden Fall mal was beklopptes ein nun denn.
Dann gabs auch ganz interessantes Feedback über verschiedene Kanäle zu dem spontan noch mal eingeworfenen brexit Teil das kam wohl ganz gut an das zu thematisieren weil.
Ja das insgesamt glaube ich auch ein bisschen unterrepräsentiert ist finde ich zumindest in unserer Medienlandschaft auch in Großbritannien trotzalledem.
Pitztal wild weiter und ja mal schauen ich denke mal ich.
Wird das Thema hier auch weiterhin begleiten und immer mal wieder eine Zusammenfassung so aus meiner Perspektive machen so sich denn was Neues ergeben hat da dürfte dann in der nächsten Zeit auch eine Menge passieren
wer Lust hat noch mal ein bisschen Hintergrund zu bekommen solange hier nicht davon die Rede ist.
Gib einerseits bei Maha in seinem Podcast Klabauter Cast eine Folge zum brexit
jüngste ist auch schon wieder fast ein wenig veraltet weil sie genau an dem Tag
aufgenommen wurde als dieser Checker steel dann verabredet wurde aber da wurden schon korrekt vorhergesagt das ist ja auch ein paar Rücktritte Rücktritte hageln
könnte du kannst ja dann auch der aus Minister und der brexit Minister Johnson und David sind ja dann zurückgetreten egal trotzdem eine sehr interessante lange Folge auch die meiner
Perspektive vorallem gut erklärt.
Was so die ganzen geschichtlichen und kulturellen politischen kulturellen Hintergründe sind für diese Entscheidung sowohl jetzt bei den Leuten als auch die Unfähigkeit der aktuellen politischen Prominenz.
Hier in unserer Firma klar Stellung zu beziehen und warum das alles so ein furchtbarer deadlock.
Wer nicht genug von allem kriegen kann ich weiß nicht ob ich das hier schon erwähnt hat ich glaube nämlich nicht deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach noch mal es gibt auch einen guten britischen brexit Podcast oder man könnte sagen Anti brexit Podcast das geht vom
Namen schon ganz gut wird das schnell klar mit der RE Maniacs Podcast wild um die aufgeklärte Menschen.
Immer das aktuelle Geschehen zusammenfassen war ist ganz interessant für mich mal so intensiver.
In so ein britischen Podcast einzusteigen habe ich erstmal wieder gemerkt wie sehr ich doch mittlerweile an den ganzen amerikanischen Diskurse und auch die Sprechweise gewöhnt bin
und musste mein ganzes Vokabular natürlich auch so ein bisschen meine Kenntnis über Prominente Figuren in Großbritannien ein wenig aktualisieren liest desto trotz
interessante Details und Gespräche rund um.
Das politische Geschehen und die potenziellen Auswirkungen des brexit oder ein bisschen sowie Logbuch Netzpolitik auch so ein bisschen immer immer gut gelaunt im Anblick der Katastrophe
von.
Ich finde es gut ich kannte die noch nicht aber mir fehlen sowieso britische Stimmen zu der ganzen brexit Thematik also hör recht viel BBC und Guardian Podcasts und
immer staunt wie wenig das brexit Thema dort dann eigentlich vorkommt es ist schon irgendwie so es gibt immer wieder Segmente dazu in der Nachricht
aber es ist jetzt eben nicht so dieses all beherrschende Thema wo man versucht dann ist man es muss eine Lösung gefunden werden wenn man nicht mal drüber redet dann ist klar dass man zu dieser Lösung nicht kommen kann,
insofern gut wenn es deine eigenen Podcast dazu.
Ja ja ist ja auch Teil Teil der.
Kritik die insbesondere aus der aufgeklärten Front auch geäußert wird das also gerade die BBC.
Guardian würde ich da fast noch mal ein bisschen rausnehmen die Bericht noch relativ viel darüber aber das unter anderem die BBC einfach das ganze Thema auch noch ein bisschen wie eine heiße Kartoffel
behandelt und sich auch in diesem wir müssen ausgewogen und neutral berichten und beide Seiten müssen zur Sprache kommen und so weiter so die Debatte die war ja ja auch in Deutschland haben gerade in der Auseinandersetzung
bitte AFD da hat noch mal ein bisschen anderen Charakter trotzdem.
Ist es teilweise schon bisschen bedauerlich wie sehr da und den heißen Brei herum getanzt wird und an der Stelle sind Podcasts dann auch eine interessante Alternative remix
gefällt mir einfach vom Stil gefällt mir vom floh und die haben auf jeden Fall den richtigen Humor am Start und vor allem laden Sie auch immer mal wieder interessante Gäste ein
also so Nick lag der ehemalige Anführer von.
The Democrats war da und diverse andere interessante Person alles Tempel.
Städtereisen das jetzt gar nicht alles aufzählen wäre noch nicht so viel Einblick in die britische Politik Geschichte hat dem wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich eh nichts sagen aber
da kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal ganz gut rein Sünden und immer wenn neuer ab so die täten stattfinden dann werden sie dort auf jeden Fall.
Ganz kurz nach der brexit hat natürlich auch eine netzpolitische Perspektive gerade wenn man somit den britischen netzpolitische nennen sie ausspricht
die haben über Jahrzehnte jetzt an der europäischen Netzpolitik mitgearbeitet und Sodingen die datenschutz-grundverordnung und letzter Teil
bitte wann die ganz vorne dabei und all das droht jetzt natürlich auch wieder weg zu brechen und im Grunde kann man das vergleichen mit einer Verhandlung über ein Freihandelsabkommen also wie bairactar oder Titel
das jetzt halt so all diese Errungenschaften der europäischen Netzpolitik für die Briten auch wiederum auf dem Spiel stehen.
Da gerade eben versucht wird mit einem sehr
ja die war ein Zugang eigentlich jede Form von Regulierung die ungewünschte ist gleich bei diesem brexit dann raus zu kicken und einfach nicht in den neuen Rechtsbeistand von Großbritannien übernehmen zu.
Genau war ganz abgesehen von so Sachen wie Roaming ECO sie natürlich so oder so nach Teilhabe.
Ja
Dann gabs Feedback zur unserer Diskussion über die EU Urheberrecht Linie sicherlich das eins der großen Themen letzte Woche.
Und ja da gibt's im Prinzip zwei Aspekte nämlich einerseits die Frage was ist denn da eigentlich wirklich beschlossen worden.
Das betrifft hat sowohl dir sehr einer urheberrechtsrichtlinie und die sprechenden Regeln dafür als eben auch den Teil Leistungsschutzrecht ganz konkret.
Weiß ich gar nicht wo fangen wir denn da an.
Naja vielleicht man grundsätzlich also
es war schon irgendwie ein herber Schlag in die Magengrube als diese Abstimmung so ausgegangen ist und vielleicht wird auch mal sinnvoll zu analysieren was denn was denn dazu geführt hat also wenn man sich das Abstimmungsverhalten ist anschaut
am
Die Konservativen haben wirklich im Block mit ihrem Berichterstatter Axel Voss gestimmt und wir hatten dann aber trotzdem viele Abzüge und viele.
Eben war Politik eigentlich von der allen Parteien Deutschland wann 7 auf einen grün oder bei mir gesagt habt ihr am Ende dann auch für das Gesetz das ganzes gestimmt haben wenn in Europa ist es so dass man zuerst über die einzelnen Änderungsanträge abst,
und dann am Ende noch mal schaut ist nur mit dem Gesamtergebnis jetzt zufrieden und schicke das weiter in den Trilog oder sagt man Nein.
Wie das jetzt ausgegangen ist denn wir uns quer und hätte da keine Mehrheit gegeben wer das Gesetz doch mit dem Tag gestorben.
An und gerade bei 2. Abstimmung haben daneben viele,
Politiker gesagt na doch wir können uns jetzt nicht ganz gegen die Urheber stellen und deswegen stimmen wir jetzt hier dafür
was in der Sache angenommen wurde ist definitiv desastroes weil Axel vor sie hat auch überhaupt nicht auf der Suche nach einem Kompromiss war sondern eigentlich immer nur versucht hat in der Argumentation auszuweichen.
Anta ist es eigentlich auch ganz bezeichnend es gab ursprünglich nämlich eine andere Berichterstatterin zu diesem dass jede Frau comodini.
Dann leider aber in die nationale Regierung von glaube ich Bulgarien gegangen ist und dadurch hat Axel Voss überhaupt das diesen Job bekommen also das wäre z.b. mit so kleinen Details wie einem
anderen Berichterstatter hätte man dieses Thema auf jeden Fall zu einem besseren Abschluss gebracht also das muss man auch irgendwie Axel force.
Anlasten dass ich hier so eine Hardcore Position vertreten hat.
An und wo das auf jeden Fall sicherlich auch zurückzuführen ist wieso wieder verloren haben ist weil einfach auch keine neutrale Berichterstattung war also es waren einfach viele.
Farm große Verlagshäuser mit ihrem Eigeninteresse beim Leistungsschutzrecht nicht gewählt beide Seiten dieser Debatte darzustellen
AMS gab ganz viele groß aufgehangen der Kommentare in den Feuilletons die für dieses Gesetz argumentiert haben an wir haben auch gesehen das automatisch
alle Leute die dagegen sind von Google gekauft sind.
Also sowohl nicht politische Aktivisten Aktivisten Angie aus aber eben auch.
Tim Berners-Lee Dafina das Wort War z
der sich kritisch geäußert hat die wurde das auch unterstellt und ich Mann ich habe dann bei dir in der Button immer den UN-Sonderberichterstatter für Meinungsfreiheit die vital genannt die sich auch kritisch geäußert hat dass die Gegenseite sind sich nicht getraut hin auch noch Google
unter die Schuhe zu schieben aber das war ihre Haupt Replik auf jeder Art von Argument die von unserer Seite kam.
Und es hat recht gut verfangen muss man besorgniserregender Weise zugestehen und da wo wo wo dieses Argument dann aber wirklich.
Besonders gefährlich wurde war das auch alle E-Mails und und Anrufe und sonstigen Kontaktmöglichkeiten Didi
Internet-Nutzer verwendet haben um sich an ihre Abgeordneten zuwenden als Spam bezeichnet wurden als google gesteuerte robots und das wurde auch gesagt das ist Robocop.
Avaz überhaupt nicht
belegt werden konnte das ist irgendwie robocalls gab die gegen upload-filter aufgetreten sind das ist ein Instrument was man aus den USA kennst wo man algentee angerufen wird und dann geht der mehr weniger in Pommern dran
und deswegen ja ist ja viel Desinformationen gepaart mit einer sehr großen Lobby macht
1a missbraucht auf jeden Fall auch eine Manöverkritik jetzt irgendwie danach weil was jetzt hier beschlossen wurde.
Wird jetzt in den trilogverhandlungen mal wahrscheinlich sich nicht verbessern sie haben schon im Parlament ein paar Sachen jetzt beschlossen vielleicht sollten wir darauf eingehen die so.
Ambra ganz kurz wo du das gerade erweckst also ich habe das auch gehört aus anderen Quellen unter anderem.
Von den Grünen das dort wohl.
Richtig viele E-Mails rein gegen die sozusagen gesagt haben alle Argumente hierfür eine freiere Regelung sind Googles astroturfing und ihr geht da sozusagen gerade dem der Lobby der Amerikaner auf den Leim.
Also ich kann nicht beurteilen wie viele Leute da sind welche Richtungen gebracht hat zeigt nur das hier offenbar würde ich auch mit harten Bandagen gekämpft wird weil das ist ja dann auch mal richtig Fake News.
Jan vorallem ist es demokratiefeindlich also wie bisher würden wir uns an gesondert paneuropäischer Öffentlichkeit wünschen dass Menschen sich wirklich interessieren für.
Ihre Demokratie für politische Entscheidungen dass wir über nationale Grenzen hinweg uns an einem europäischen Gesetzgebungsprozess beteiligen das ist ja eine enorme würde für Menschen
sich mal wirklich einzulesen in ein Thema sich selber sicher genug zu sein mit ihrer Meinung dass sie sich dann an ihre Abgeordneten wenden und da ist eine große Hürde dahinter und Didi.
Wir sagen immer ja das Beste ist wenn ihr anruft oder wenn ihr selber eure eigenen E-Mail schreibt in euren eigenen Wort.
Aber die meisten Leute haben halt nicht die Zeit.
Selbst zu formulieren und Schaffens dann hat gerade mal irgendwie bei den Petitionen mitzumachen oder bei solchen Massen E-Mails die dann ausgeschickt werden.
Und das meinte ich mit Manöverkritik gleichzeitig dass man überhaupt.
Best GTA IV Standards dir an der Stelle greifen dass man z.b. auch bei solchen vorgefertigten E-Mails den Namen und auch die E-Mail-Adresse,
der jeweiligen Personen mit übermittelt das ist die Möglichkeit gibt dort auch nachzufragen
viele Abgeordneten zumindest die die irgendwie nicht ganz Bürgerverein sind schreiben auch Antwort-E-Mail so sind dann auch seiner IV Text der aber die wollen sich zurückmelden und die wollen.
Auch zeigen wir lesen was ihr uns schreibt an sich ist das ja der feuchte Traum eines Europaabgeordneten wenn er endlich mal von seinem Bürgern und seinen WählerInnen hört
aber das ist eben hier komplett ins Gegenteil verkehrt ist ist auch ein extremer Dämpfer für Menschen die sich hier vielleicht zum ersten Mal in den politischen Prozess.
Ja also so ist es jetzt aber auf jeden Fall bekommen jetzt müssen wir damit leben ist dass ich die Frage was.
Steckt nun eigentlich wirklich drin Airforce Shenia selber kurz danach nicht so richtig genau zu wissen was er denn jetzt eigentlich beschlossen wurde.
Ja es gab da eine Ausnahme die sms wurde in den letzten Metern vor der ab
Stimmung noch mal einen Änderungsantrag reingebracht der an kann sich genau wiedergeben 9 Schutz für geistiges Eigentum für.
Etabliert und das ist halt vorallem da
Tagen frohe Fotos in Stadien gemacht werden vor allem eben im Fußball wo sehr oft irgendwie so Zusammenstellungen gibt von den besten Toren diese Woche dass all diese Dinge dann eben noch leichter runter genommen werden können das ist vor allem auch ein Problem für Journalisten
weil wenn du irgendwie aus dem Stadion Berichterstattung machst und dann brauchst du die Zustimmung von DFB oder FIFA bevor du diese Fotos verwenden kannst kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass,
A 1 Chemnitz Vorberichterstattung sein kann.
Ja gut ich meine das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt schon so das wird wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe jetzt auch noch dein gehen
schlimmer als dass es sich jetzt eben auch ohne weiteres auf den Amateurbereich auch noch ausdehnen Kanada der DFB als offizieller Veranstalter dieser ganzen Liga Dinger da gabs ja auch schon Fälle dass sie eben gegen Plattformen,
vorgegangen sind wo halt so Kreisliga Berichterstattung gemacht wird mit eigenem Videomaterial ne.
So und das könnte noch unangenehmer werden.
Ja es ist halt eine weitere Verschärfung des Urheberrechts an einer Stelle wo es klare Geschäftsinteressen gibt aber es ist halt eben keine Reform des Urheberrechts die wirklich die das kreative Schaffen
und das Nutzen von Kultur im Blick hat diese ursprüngliche Anspruch des Urheberrechts diesen Interessenausgleich zwischen diesen beiden Gruppen
hinzubekommen der ist halt neben diesen riesigen Industrien die da dran hängen komplett aus dem Fokus geraten an das ist auch die Grund
diese Reform
es gibt aber gute Sachen werden Uwe Vertragsrecht und und eben auch grundsätzlich das ist das YouTube irgendwie ja Geld ab
muss ich jetzt auch keine schlechte Sache glaube ich da fehlt irgendwie aber auch noch die Transparenz über das was YouTube z.b. der GEMA zahlt
und den anderen Ländern zahlt aber ansich ist die es gibt ja schon auch gute Elemente das Problem ist halt.
Das ist die Kollateralschäden viel zu groß sind und vielleicht sollten wir mal kurz reden was jetzt hier vorallem Artikel 13 drinnen steht
der Text jetzt angenommen wurde hat nämlich auch eine gewisse Einschränkung bei den Online-Plattformen giert upload-filter im
untersteht ebenso für Inhalte bezogen durch wiedergabe Verschlagwortung verwahren und Sequenzierung der hochgeladenen Werkes braucht sozusagen seine aktive Behandlung der
Inhalte die da hochgeladen werden es muss user-generated-content sein.
Also wenn ich nur auf meinem eigenen Blog poste ohne Kommentarfunktion oder wir ziehen Podcast haben brauchen wir noch keinen.
Upload-filter nach diesem Gesetz und es muss dann eben auch in der Optimierung zum Zweck der Gewinnerzielung Bewerbung und folglich aktiv.
Behandlung dieser Inhalte vollführt werden und es gibt dann auch Ausnahmen.
Also und kommerzieller Dienste die Online-Enzyklopädie sind explizit genannt und wissenschaftlicher Verzeichnisse und Cloud-Dienste werden auch noch mal genannt als explizite Ausnahme was.
Gut dieser Text jetzt ja eigentlich wir haben immer noch eine extrem breite Definition von dem was man vielleicht aktivweb Online-Plattformen nennen könnte
das ist eine Unterscheidung zu den klassischen Hostern wenn ich einfach nur irgendwie Webspace habe wo Leute ihre
Inhalte Ihre Website hochladen können freilich noch nicht unter dieses Gesetz sondern ich brauche irgendeine aktive Behandlung dieser Inhalte aber für all das was unter diese aktive Behandlung Velten das ist das wirklich von kleinem.
Forum bisschen zu Facebook
gibt's nur noch ganz sehr spezielle Ausnahmen wie eben dieser unseren Enzyklopädien oder
getappt ist ja mit den Open Source Ausnahme gemeint oder eben sowas wie Dropbox das heißt was exo-force hier gemacht hat ist er hat eine extrem breite Definition geschaffen und dann sehr enge Ausnahmen.
Geschaffen und die Ausnahmen sind auch direkt zurückzuführen auf die Unternehmen oder Gruppen die Wikipedia die es geschafft haben der Lobbyisten hin zu schicken zu Fuß zu den Berichterstatter und wie ihre speziellen Interessen.
Eine Ausnahme bekommen haben und alles was an innovativen Diensten vielleicht noch.
Geschaffen wird aber vor allem eben die die es jetzt schon gibt die Jungs nicht hin geschafft haben fallen halt hier unter die Regelung und sind ein Kollateralschaden.
Also sowas wie tinder tripadvisor oder Booking.com würden alle weiterhin unter diese Regelung fallen.
Und das ist immer noch an Norbert Kollateralschaden den glaube ich auch viele Plattformen nicht bereit sind zu stemmen also.
Wenn dieses Gesetz Sutur geht rechne ich damit das auch viele.
Websitebetreiber in anderen Regionen dieser Welt einfach sagen werden wir blocken den gesamten Europäischen IP Ranger.
Wir sind das ja teilweise heute schon bei der datenschutzgrundverordnung das vor einem gewissen useit sagen wenn wir eure Werbung hier irgendwie nicht mit Profiling ausliefern können.
Dann blockieren wir einfach europäische NutzerInnen.
Und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass wir das jetzt vermehrt noch mal im Bezug auf diese upload-filter sehen werden.
Die Sicherheit auch einfach viele Unternehmen nicht leisten können.
Es gibt es auch immer Berichte die Zahlen nennen wie teuer eigentlich die Entwicklung von Content-ID dem Upload Filter von YouTube für google war.
Anzahl keine unternehmen können das definitiv nicht zu stemmen wenn Google seine upload-filter nicht herausgibt dann befürchte ich auch dass wir upload-filter von der Urheberrechts Industrie sehen werden.
Die dann hattest du Zusagen selbst ihre Inhalte dort versuchen zu identifizieren.
Und dann überlässt man die Erkennung von dem was er über Rechtsverstoß ist halt denen die damit Geld verdienen dass auch keine gute Lösung.
Wobei das ja zumindest.
Zumindest in dem Moment an die Lasten von denen getragen werden Dir auch versuchen ihre Rechte wahrzunehmen also ich meine wenn es zum ist sowas wie eine eine registrierte Datenbank von urheberrechtlichen also von klar zuordnen waren erbrechtlichen Material gelbe
und so etwas kann man konsultieren ja man kann aber auch vielleicht mit anderen Quellen gegenprüfen könnte das ja vielleicht auch noch einen Weg nehmen mit dem man leben könnte aber das ist derzeit habe ich noch nicht absehbar.
Es gab Änderungsanträge die genauso ein Register von eurem rechtlich geschützten Werken vorgesehen head
und der kam ursprünglich von der Liberalen Abgeordneten marithe starke und das wäre eine Verbesserung gewesen in der Hinsicht hat
leider keinen.
Wieso einige Details in diesem ganzen Paket auch ein weiterer Teil.
Ist ja Leistungsschutzrecht ich glaube da ist noch überhaupt nicht klar was das jetzt für Folgen haben würde man muss immer sagen würde dass wir wollen die so tun als ob hier schon alles beschlossen ist beschlossen ist das kann man nur noch wiederholen
geschlossen ist das aktuelle Statement zum Vorschlag also das Date mit des Parlaments zum Vorschlag der Kommission.
Didi Gesprächsbasis für den Trilog bietet das was in den Verhandlungen rauskommt muss dann noch mal vom Parlament bestätigt werden.
Dort kann es theoretisch auch noch mal komplett gekippt werden das Halten aber glaube ich alle Beteiligten für sehr.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein
uphill battle das jetzt in zweiter Lesung noch mal zu kippen aber ich glaube es führt kein Weg dran vorbei also.
Also die trilogverhandlungen werden nichts gutes verheißen weil
die Didi an Logik in Europa ist immer dass man sobald Positionen gefällt wurden dann eigentlich nur noch versucht sich zwischen diesen beiden Positionen zu reinigen und nachdem sowohl Kommission.
Rat der Mitgliedstaaten und Parlament alle upload-filter vorsehen wird das Trio gegebenes auch upload-filter beinhalten und die können dann aber immer noch in zweiter Lesung
am geändert oder rausgestrichen werden dafür braucht man aber immer eine eine größere mehr dann als vertreten mehr hat glaube ich anstimmen oder man kann auch das gesamte Gesetzeswerk in zweiter Lesung
ablehnend dann wäre das gesamte Gesetz tot es gibt schon historische Beispiele dass wir das geschafft haben wenn man sich zurück erinnert an
Acta oder ne Zentralität das waren zwei sehr wichtige netzpolitische Abstimmungen die alle auch nicht so ausgesehen hätten dass wir das noch mal gewinnen können.
Und dann haben wir es trotzdem geschafft weil Europaabgeordnete kurz vor der Wahl.
Sich dann halt doch dran erinnern dass die die Wählerinnen und Wähler die sich da bei Ihnen melden vielleicht keine Bots sind sondern legitime Interessen haben.
Und jetzt gilt es halt irgendwie die besten Wege zu finden sich an
die Abgeordneten zuwenden und Dakar zu machen dass man
potentielle Wähler ist ja hier in der ganz klare Haltung hat und sich von den Abgeordneten erwartet dass Sie hier auch dementsprechend abstimmen wenn sie wieder gewählt werden wollen also es gibt schon auch da
bitte ganzen reptiliengehirn dass ich irgendwann mal einschaltet und denkt so Überlebensinstinkt wenn ich mein Mandat behalten will sollte ich vielleicht,
genau das Gegenteil von dem machen was was mich hier massiv angetragen wird das ist jetzt die Situation vor der wir stehen.
AMS ist frühestens Ende dieses Jahres erwartbar dass wir zu dieser Abstimmung in zweiter Lesung im Europaparlament kommen wahrscheinlicher ist jänner Februar alles.
Die Beispiele gerade genannt hast akta und Netzneutralität waren aber jetzt nicht in zweiter Lesung ne waren das ist immer schon im Vorfeld schon.
Netto Tollität war erste Lesung und da was aber auch so dass wir.
Der vorherigen der Ausschuss Meinung ziemlich viel verloren haben und dann ähnlich wie das jetzt hier zuletzt war mit Änderungsanträgen im Plenum in der ersten Lesung Normalwert Erreger.
Zum umgerissen haben bei Aida
weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr dass man Freihandelsabkommen da konnte das Europaparlament sowieso nur JA oder NEIN sagen.
Vielleicht gab es da eine erste Lesung mit dem was das Parlament der Kommission aufträgt zu verhandeln aber dann verhandelt die Kommission und was da rauskommt kann Rat und Parlament nur annehmen oder ablehnen
ohne Gipfel was halten ja nein wo der in unserem Sinne.
Ja dann lass uns Schutzrecht gab's noch so ein bisschen Feedback damit der Hinweis auf einen interessanten.
Artikel auf heise Google brainwood da beschrieben eine Software die mit KI selbständig Wikipedia-Artikel schreibt.
Mike schreibt uns
Hi kurz und Leistungsschutzrecht google arbeitet schon länger in einer KI zur Textzusammenfassung und auch zusammenfassung Neuformulierung aus mehreren Quellen damit es die automatische Zusammenfassung eines News Artikels auf beliebige Größe möglich mehrere Quellen anzuzapfen
daraus neue Langform Artikel zu generieren.
Die Kirsche auf der Sahne meine Prognose google liefert über seine Plattform nach LSR durch KI gesammelt und zusammengefasste News ein Ding oder Quelle wird Google womöglich gar nicht angeben da es womöglich dutzende Artikel sind
bitte den Google News Text beitragen soll quasi dazwischen zu quatschen robotisierte
Journalist wird hier geschaffen oder Artikel werden mit einer Zusammenfassung gezeigt
die von der KI generiert sind und kein Zitat könnte gut sein dass Artikel nicht bald nur noch Rohstoffe für Googles KI sind die weiterverarbeitet und für Sprachassistent und Web suchen informierten aufbereitet.
Ja alles vorstellbar ich denke dass Google generell genug Möglichkeiten hat hier sich außer,
Pflicht zu stehlen irgendetwas zu vergüten oder irgendwas machen zu müssen Mann hat das ja schon gesehen in Spanien haben sie einfach Google News eingestellt und
der Gewinner ähnliche verschaffen auf europäischer Ebene stattfinden würde naja Bundesanleihe einfach auch sein lassen der Schaden wäre dann halt trotzdem.
Weißt du was.
Das ist das ist geil das ist wirklich geile so dass es wenn dieses Szenario so kommt Texte die einen Computer schreibt unterstehen kann woher reicht.
Gibt kein Urheber aber sie fallen unter das Leistungsschutzrecht das Leistungsschutzrecht liegt ja.
Presseverleger und nicht bei den einzelnen Journalisten das heißt wenn Google jetzt hier irgendwie sich eine fehle Verlag Lizenz in irgendeinem Land Shop dann haben die ein Leistungsschutzrecht an diesen künstlich generierte Nut
wie könnte sozusagen dann theoretisch Lizenz Abgaben dafür verlangen wenn die an irgendeiner anderen Stelle verwendet werden das ist natürlich dann aber endgültig der,
Fotojournalismus und ja.
Sehr skurril aber ja ich sitz hier einfach wieder einmal dass dieses Leistungsschutzrecht absolut.
Gut wofür ist angeblich geschaffen wurde hinter verschlossener Hand sagen dass auch die großen Verlage ich gab hauptsächlich SC Axel Springer der hinter diesem Gesetz steht.
Und Julia hat da bei uns in in Linz auf einer Podiumsdiskussion mal darüber berichtet dass der Anwalt von Axel Springer ist sie den im Rechtsausschuss des Europaparlaments hatten auch ganz klar gesagt hat Sie rechnen nicht damit das über das Leistungsschutzrecht.
Irgendwelche Einnahmen an die Verlage kommen werden einfach bei die Anwaltskosten zu hoch sind und wenn man sich eh nicht einig wird aber man will Aggregatoren aus.
Dem US-Markt rausdrängen und sollte das wirklich die die Absicht sein.
Dann würde natürlich so eine automatisierte Zusammenfassung von den einzelnen texten normal einen erheblich dazu beitragen dass genau das Gegenteil erreicht wird von dem wofür das Leistungsschutzrecht jetzt politisch gefordert wurde
Armband das ist einfach so eine kurzsichtige Regulierung ich glaube mir es noch nie ein dümmeres Gesetz untergekommen ist.
Ja ja aber schaun wir doch mal weiter was es noch für Auswirkung geben könnte.
Denn gerade jetzt diese Forderung nach Upload filtern scheint ja auch die.
Fantasie auf EU-Ebene Zug zum Blühen zu bringen.
Demnächst wird über schon die nächste Generation von Terror filtern also nächste Folge die nächste Generation von Filtern diskutiert in dem Fall Anti-Terror Filter.
Ja also es hat er genau genommen für dich.
Es hat nicht lange gedauert dieses Konzept von Upload filtern was wir jetzt hier gerade diskutieren was ist im Zuge der unberechtigt gehen jetzt wahrscheinlich kommen wird
das ist ja schon länger innerhalb der EU-Kommission etwas mit dem man liebäugelt also es gibt Aussagen von dem EU Kommissar Andrus Ansip der der sagt ja mit
Content-ID von Google werden wir.
Ah jetzt irgendwie das Terra Problemlösen und des Urheberrechts Problemlösen wenn man
den den Anhörungen von Mark Zuckerberg im amerikanischen Senat geh zu gelacht hat dann hat man auch gehört dass er dich beeilen Fragen nach Inhalts Moderation
deine Antwort immer künstliche Intelligenz das scheint sowieso die Stoßrichtung zu sein in die Silicon Valley geht.
Arneis habe ich zuletzt in Neuseeland irgendwie man man das Urheberrechtsgesetz reformieren,
wollte hat Google auch irgendwie gemeint gab in Europa schreiben Sie jetzt Content-ID ins Gesetz probiert das doch damit.
Also das ist sogar nicht ein Zufall dass wir ja dass wir hier auf einmal überall über algorithmische Entscheidungen über Inhalte sprechen sondern das hat System
An und.
Da muss mal kurz in die Story gehen wir haben ja in Europa schon seit einigen Jahren jetzt immer wieder Antiterrorgesetze die verabschiedet werden und es gab auch kürzlich eine
Anti Terrorismus Richtlinie die schon vor ein paar Jahren verabschiedet wurde und da stand auch ursprünglich schon upload-filter trennen.
Die hat man aber damals in federführend Neubürger Rechtsausschuss dem lieber Ausschluss rausgestrichen
A und dieser Richtlinie die ist schon längst beschlossen die musste auch schon vor einigen Tagen umgesetzt werden also die Deadline war genau
4 Tage bevor es neue Gesetz vorgestellt wurde nämlich die antiterrorismusverordnung die jetzt wieder upload-filter
beinhaltet für extremistische und terroristische Inhalte
a Monsters Gustostück ist dass diese dieses neue Gesetz hat Jean-Claude Juncker in seiner Rede zur Lage der Union vorgestellt und zwar um 9 Uhr früh
und um 12 Uhr dreißig Uhr wurde dann über upload-filter im Urheberrechtsgesetz abgestimmt
also noch bevor das Parlament sich äußern konnte hat die Kommission dieses Gesetz rausgelassen wo wiederum upload-filter drin stehen.
Genau genommen geht es bei diesem Gesetz um eine Verpflichtung von Host-Provider also hier geht's wirklich um jede Art von.
Online-Plattform und das beinhaltet auch winzig kleine Blocks und das beinhaltet vor allem auch.
Jedes Ein-Mann-Unternehmen wo irgendwo Webspace angeboten wird sobald dort irgendwie extremistische Inhalte sind die gemeldet werden müssen diese innerhalb von einer Stunde runter genommen werden.
Unter gewissen Bedingungen müssen auch proaktive Maßnahmen eingesetzt werden dass derartige Inhalte nicht noch mal hochgeladen werden.
Und das ist insgesamt noch mal eine große Schritt in die Richtung.
Von dem dem etablieren von solchen filtern und auch eine extrem gefährlicher wie soll man sagen.
Wenn ich irgendwie mir überlegen würde jetzt noch ein Unternehmen zu gründen und irgendwas mit user-generated-content zu machen dann muss man schon sehr mutig sein dass noch in Europa zu tun und nicht sofort in die USA oder nach Asien zu gehen.
Am weil dieser ist dieses Umfeld das hier geschaffen wird ist halt,
wirklich gefährlich sind die Strafen die mit dieser Verordnung vorgesehen sind wenn man sicher nicht an dieser sperr Verfügungen hält sind genauso hoch wie bei der datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Also es droht ja auch eine Strafe mit bis zu 4% des globalen Konzernumsatz ist und das ist eine eine Größe wo man daneben auch als
ab wann wenn man schonmal solche Inhalte hat wenn es irgendwelche Trolle gibt
die auf der Agenda Plattform sich herum tummeln wird man anfangen overblocking zu betreiben
wird man anfangen jeder Art von irgendwie auch nur potentiell kritischen Aussagen präventiv normal zu sperren und zu löschen weil man nicht in die Patrouille kommen will so eine hohe Strafe zu zahlen.
Aber wo kommt denn wo kommt denn jetzt diese diese Gesetzesinitiative auf einmal her ich meine wir befinden uns hier auf den letzten Metern dieser Legislatur
im nächsten Mai wird neues Parlament gewählt wesentlichen ist das Parlament doch jetzt alles damit beschäftigt
all das noch durch zu also ich will das Parlament die komplette EU Bürokratie ist damit beschäftigt all diese ganzen Gesetze die in den letzten Jahren angeschoben wurden und die man sich für diese Legislatur als sie gesetzt hat umzusetzen
wie ungewöhnlich ist denn dass das jetzt so kurzfristig etwas kommt oder ist schon länger das im Gespräch wärmst du nicht.
AMS es gab immer wieder gemunkelt dass das kommen wird offiziell verlautbart wurde dass es so etwas ähnliches geben könnte ende August da gab's Sonderkommission sehr
kontrolliert Informationen die an einzelnen Medien gingen ohne wirklich den Gesetzestext durchblicken zu lassen so dass es keine gültigen Stimmen gab
darf das war der erste newcycle zu dieser Menderes muss gesetzt und er daneben im Rahmen dieser Lage der Union hat das Junker vorgestellt und auch wiederum.
Zuerst die ganze PRO und dazu ganz viele seid documents also das war ein richtiger Dokument,
Dampfgarer Enten in ins Netz gestellt wurde das war dann II newcycle dir auch wiederum sehr
oberflächlich war weil die meisten schon alliston
gerade eben mit dem Brüssel Korrespondenten die oft nur 12 Personen sind und sich um alle Themen kümmern müssen die haben da noch nicht irgendwie
direkt ins Gesetz reingeschaut oder auf die kritischen Stimme gehört die am mit wenigen Ausnahmen den Gesetzestext vorher nicht hatte.
An und das hat zur zugefüttert II newcycle zu diesem Gesetz auch wiederum nur positiv war
Ja und an Dritte News-Seite gibt's bei europäischen Themen eigentlich nicht wenn die zweimal berichtet wurden dann sind sie durch und dann wird es schon sehr schwierig damit in einer Redaktionssitzung irgendeiner Aufmerksamkeit für ein EU Thema zu bekommen
M&S ist auch du hast schon richtig erkannt das irgendwie jetzt so wenige Monaten vor der Europawahl zu machen ist es crazy hat aber auch System also.
Das Netzwerk alität Gesetz die mir damals so viel mit gearbeitet habe wurde auch im September 2013 vorgestellt und im Mai 2014 war dann Europa.
Also die Kommission.
Dieses Fenster dieses Zeitfenster wahrscheinlich im Kalender markiert wo sie wissen okay aber den ganz konträr seelensachen die wir aber einfach durchbringen müssen oder wo es auch so einen Ballon gibt dann den wir dran hängen können.
Machen Baden wir irgendwie bis ganz zuletzt dass es keine lange Debatte mehr über das Gesetz geben kann bei Netto Realität an sie dazu Formen verwendet
um diese dieses Anti ne Zentralität Gesetz auf jeden Fall noch vor der Wahl wenigstens durchs Parlament zu brennen.
Und hier gehe ich davon aus dass die Kommission des Terrorismus Thema einfach dafür verwendet um auf jeden Fall mal im Rad
eine ganz harte Positionierung zu bekommen und der wird ja auch nicht neu gewählt aber die Staats und Regierungschefs sind wahrscheinlich immer mehrheitlich für Antiterrorgesetze.
Vor allem gerade dieses Gesetz mit den Upload filtern war eine politische Forderung die wie es genauso schon gehört haben von deutschen französischen großbritannische neolithischen ene Ministern.
Also da
kann man auch ein paar Monate zurückgehen und man findet die Aussagen für wenn das Verlinken wo genau das noch mal gefordert wurde.
Und wie gesagt damals bei der Anti Terrorismus Richtlinie ANSYS nicht geschafft damit durchzukommen und deswegen jetzt hier bei der Verordnung.
Versucht man es wirklich mit dem radikalsten Entwurf noch mal.
Am und wir haben ja immer davor gewarnt dass er auch in der ganzen upload-filter Debatte in dem Urheberrechtsgesetz war mein Argument immer sobald wir so eine Zensur Infrastruktur mal etabliert haben egal für welches Thema.
Wird die ausgewertet werden dann werden wir auch diese und jene und andere Inhalte auch auf allen Plattformen auf einem Schlag gesperrt wissen wollen.
Amon das ist ein ganz gefährliche. Weil ab diesem Zeitpunkt sobald ein Star zu eine contro.
Über die jede Meinungsäußerung
dann über ein grundfix verheilt sozusagen getunt und verfeinert werden kann wird man so eine Stellschraube als Starts verwenden um auch noch andere politische Ziele zu erreichen und genau das passiert.
Ja und vor allem was ist ja schon erwähnt nebenbei aber ich glaube das kann man noch mal betonen gescheitert ist vorher eine Richtlinie geplant ist jetzt eine Verordnung und selbige ist ja quasi die
starker wirkende rechtliche Variante eine EU-Verordnung siehe datenschutzgrundverordnung
gilt sofort unmittelbar und in allen Ländern auf dieselbe Art und Weise und von daher sozusagen das schärfste Schwert was die Europäische Kommission überhaupt,
auspacken kann.
Genau und einer Richtlinie im Gegenzug ist sozusagen das Kochrezept für eingesetzt dass die EU verabschiedet und dann müssen die Mitgliedstaaten bis zu einer fixen Frist diese Gesetze selber schreiben und national in ihrem Parlament.
Erlassen ansonsten gibt es einen Vertragsverletzungsverfahren und gerade beim Urheberrecht wie eine Verordnung aber gut gewesen weil dann hätten wir nicht mehr 28 Urheberrechte sondern nur noch ein europäisches
Amon das wäre gut gewesen und gleichzeitig jetzt wird diesen ganzen Unklarheiten bei Leistungsschutzrecht und Upload fehlt,
rechne ich auch mit massiven Verschlechterung also Polen und Ungarn dürfen jetzt Gesetze für upload-filter schreiben an wenn man schon dabei ist.
Beierfelder mir vielleicht noch was ein
an ich muss mir noch mal kurz ergänzen ich habe vorher war dein Upload filtern die jetzt beschlossen wurden eine Sache vergessen und ich will Axel Force ja irgendwie nicht unterstellen er hat noch eine Ausnahme für
micro enterprises reingeschrieben also upload-filter musst du erst machen wenn du ich habe sonst 5 Millionen Umsatz hast als Unternehmen
also gerade kleine Plattformbetreiber werden unter dieser Grenze bleiben und müssen deswegen noch keine upload-filter etablieren aber wenn ich einen.
Start up in wenn ich ein Unternehmen Gründe wenn ich irgendwie eine App oder irgendwas habe das erfolgreich mit user-generated-content umgeht
da bin ich sehr schnell über diesen fünf Millionen und vor allem geht's was keinen Internetunternehmen was dauerhaft vorhat und fünf Millionen zu bleiben.
Sprich mal kommt trotzdem wieder in dieses Argument des Wirtschaftsstandortes und des innovationshemmnisse centre Anti Terror Verordnung jetzt wiederum
gibt's sowas überhaupt nicht wie gesagt auch der kleine ein Mann Poster
fällt unter dieses Gesetz muss jetzt auch mit solchen technischen Maßnahmen innerhalb von einer Stunde alles sperren
was dem Vernehmen nach aufgrund von einer kompetent of forty die kein Richter sein muss als extremistischer Inhalt.
Gut um uns wieder ein bisschen zu beruhigen schauen wir mal nach Deutschland glaubt wird uns nicht gelingen ja.
Da hatten wir uns ja letzte Woche über anmaßen unterhalten und was hilft für einen maßlosen,
Kommunikationsstil an den Tag legt insbesondere was das ausplaudern von Internas betrifft für die andere des politisch engagierte Journalisten auch schnell mal des Landes Fahrrad ist angehört
den Landesverrat vorgeworfen bekommen mit Narkose sell deswegen nicht.
Da gab es zunächst einmal noch Korrektur von unseren Hörern wurde darauf hingewiesen also ich glaube Linus hatte gesagt dass ja die AFD nicht im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium.
Also das Gremium was im Bundestag ist sich von.
Verfassungsschutz ab und zu mal was erzählen lassen darf welcher Farbe sieht da die Wände gestrichen haben dass sie.
Adia dort nicht vertreten sei trotz ihrer Bundestagsfraktion diese erstellen
das war unglücklich formuliert selbstverständlich hat die AFD dort ein Vertreter das hat zwar eine Weile gedauert er musste um die glaube ich erst im zweiten und dritten Wahlgang
bestätigt werden Roman Johannes Reusch.
Der Prinz Oberstaatsanwalt ist was mir auch mal wieder einen kalten Schauer den Rücken laufen lässt wie viel Leute wie er so in der Stadt Justiz.
Haben die sich der AFD anschließen allerdings und da passt es dann auch wieder zusammen.
Sind diese ganzen Haushaltsfragen die wir angesprochen haben oder beziehungsweise dermaßen wohl angesprochen hat gegenüber Hand Brandner.
Aufgabe des Vertrauens Gremiums was wiederum so eine Unterordnung des Haushaltsausschusses ist was im besondere geheime Belange hat und da ist die AFD mitnichten vertreten also so oder so die Sache bleibt Fischi.
Die Bundestags Webseite ist am übrigen auch nicht besonders hilfreich was man dazu sagen also ich glaube Linus hatte sich das ein bisschen vertan und kam dann irgendwie über die gebotenen links oder suche Einträge auf die Informationen aus dem letzten Bundestag.
Ansonsten.
Garten auf die Debatte was denn Maßen überhaupt so öffentlich zu sagen.
Erlaubt ist tatsächlich war es wohl so dass er sehr wohl das Recht eingeräumt bekommen hat
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit machen wir das hier kurz angesprochen ich glaube ich sagte das ist ja wohl auch nicht sein kann was hatte der hier Interviews bei der Bild-Zeitung zugeben grundsätzlich ist Öffentlichkeitsarbeit eben aber durchaus gestattet gewesen.
Allerdings.
Ich habe ich Seehofer eingeführtes war vorher nicht.
Da kann gut sein das kann wohl sein was ich jetzt wiederum nicht.
So oder so muss und das wird im verfassungsblog in einem länglichen Beitrag schön ausgeführt formuliert der Grundsatz der Neutralität gewahrt werden was hier.
Nicht erfolgte zitiere mal aus diesem Artikel staatliche Stellen haben wenn sie sich öffentlich äußern anders als Privatperson die sich auf die grundrechtlich geschützte Meinungsfreiheit.
Bitte rufen können bestimmte Standard der Kommunikation einzuhalten zu den elementaren Rechtmäßigkeit Anforderungen gehört.
Dass sie sich im Rahmen ihres Aufgaben und Zuständigkeitsbereich bewegen dass die Information inhaltlich richtig sind und sachlich gehalten werden.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat diese Anforderung zunächst mit Blick auf Werbekampagnen der Bundesregierung formuliert und sie dann für staatliche Warnungen und einzelne Äußerungen von Regierungsmitgliedern konkretisiert.
Weiter heißt es politische Bewertung und Positionierung im palai.
In parteipolitischen Konflikten solange sie sich erkennbar auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes bewegen.
Gehören nicht dazu die Äußerung in der Bild-Zeitung die den BFV Präsidenten in den letzten Wochen zu einer umfangreichen Selbstinterpretation genötigt haben unterlaufen daher die Standards der Richtigkeit und der Neutralität.
Welche der verschiedenen Deutungsmöglichkeiten man auch zugrunde legen mag ja und das.
Bringt uns dann auch zu dem Maßen Upgrade was diese Woche stattgefunden hat ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau.
Was man dazu habt noch sagen soll.
Wirst ja sicherlich auch verfolgt haben Thomas die SPD hat sich dann mal auf Hinterbeine gestellt oder zumindest so getan als ob.
Weil das ja nun alles überhaupt nicht geht da stimme ich ja auch durchaus zu und werde dich schon eigentlich auf dich.
Das Echo wartete was irgendwann dermaforum Unfall Prozess dann ausgelöst wird bei der SPD blieb danach erstmal ruhig.
Weil das ganze dann erstmal verschoben wurde weiß nicht so ganz genau ob man wirklich so lange drüber nachdenken musste aber Angela Merkel weiter noch in Algerien und II auf jeden Fall wurde das dann auf Dienstag dieser Woche
verschoben und RAS wurde bekannt gegeben dass Herr Maaßen als Chef des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz abgesetzt wird.
Hurra dachte man sich nur dann kam die schöne Zusatzinformation da er jetzt wieder joinen.
Also da er seinen Job los ist ist er ja wieder frei.
Oder dachte der Horst aus dem Innenministerium er könnte dir allein gleich mal einstellen und dann Staatssekretär einsetzen im Innenministerium.
Was rein.
Wahrscheinlich zuständig für Integra.
Ja das ist jetzt mehr für cybersicherheit und und Bundespolizei und öffentliche Sicherheit et cetera also genau da wo man so ein Vogel eigentlich überhaupt nicht haben wollte das sein nach seiner Nähe dass er der dokumentierten Nähe zur AFD.
Und so ganz nebenbei
ist es ja auch so Stadtsekretär kann man nicht einfach mal so eben dazu beschließen sondern die kosten ja Geld und wenn so eine Rochade dann gemacht wird müsste im Prinzip an anderer Stelle auf Geld verzichtet werden
da dachte sich der Bundesforst na ja ist ja kein Problem
wir haben ja hier noch ein Staatssekretär von der SPD den können wir dann mal in Rente schicken
und wart ihr dann auch in der Pressekonferenz dann halt jetzt das Opfer und der Staatssekretär
Gunther Adler der allgemein als anerkannter Fachmann im Ressort Bauen gilt der muss dann halt gehen.
Lustigerweise hat sich ja der Osteopath diese Baugeschichte durch dieses umdichten des Innenministeriums und heimatministerium überhaupt erst nach dieser Wahl neu zugelegt und
jetzt kotzen am wischen alle in der Sehne die sich Donner versuchen in und Werner Forum für ein menschengerechte Weiterentwicklung der Wohnungssituation in Deutschland einzusetzen dass ihn jetzt auch noch die einzige kompetente crafta im Innenministerium
auch noch verloren geht
na ja da wird gerade viel hin und her gerudert und das ganze hat natürlich einerseits den Druck auf die SPD wiederum erhöht weil diese Woche haben sie dich überhaupt gar keinen.
Sinn macht
in dem Kontext deswegen überhaupt dir das gandal erst aufgebrochen ist dass er nämlich Informationen an die AFD geht das hat nachweislich ja auch Sympathisant der AFD SC unter zurim auch noch die ganzen
der unglaubliche Vorgänge in Chemnitz versucht hat in ein falsches Licht zu stellen und als Desinformationskampagne gebrandmarkt hat obwohl er eben danach auf Nachfrage nicht in der Lage war hier entspringende Fakten zu liefern die seine Aussagen auch nur ansatzweise,
Stutzen da kann doch Rossa Seehofer ich ihn eigentlich zum BKA-Chef machen wollte also der Typ.
Ja das war dann wohl mit der SPD auch nicht zu machen bei Staatssekretär wann sie dann irgendwie dabei,
man merkt dass ihr Einfluss hier an der Stelle auch begrenzt ist auf jeden Fall Helme und Sport haben sie jetzt auch wieder auf jeden Fall wieder sicher und man merkt so richtig wie die Angst vor einer Regierungskrise
meine nicht nicht dass wenn ich am laufenden Meter eine hätten in den letzten Wochen und zwar immer ausgelöst durch dieselbe Person durchaus Seehofer.
Nicht also nicht dass es jetzt eine Regierungskrise Namen wäre aber das Scheitern der Regierungskoalition wird natürlich gemeinhin als allerschlimmste angesehen was ich auch nachvollziehen kann wäre sicherlich nicht gut,
ja schon gar nicht in der aktuellen gesamteuropäischen Situation aber mit durchgestreckt da,
durchgestreckten Rücken kann die SPD hier auf jeden Fall nicht durch die Öffentlichkeit.
Schönes Zitat von Kollege Falk Steiner Horst wirft Adler raus damit Platz für Kuckucksei ist was eine Schlagzeile.
Edward Snowden hat er auch noch was zu Zwittern dazu und hat er mal auf Deutsch getwittert und man ob Maßen Agent des SVR oder FSB ist kann derzeit nicht belegt werden.
Aber ist eine Anspielung war die Maßen derjenige der Snowden unterstellt hat ein Agent des FSB zu sein also das.
Was meint ihr denn mit svra da bin ich hier oder ich gerade.
Svrs an andere russischer Geheimdienst sich gehabt der der sowas der Auslandsgeheimdienst fspca der inneren Geheimnis unter Nachfolger des.
Aber ich ich ich mache mich die ganze Zeit wieso machen diese Politiker dass ich meine die die die die SPD.
Wozu ist die in der Regierung wenn sie jetzt hier nicht irgendwie klar Kante zeigen kann wannigmann
Merkel hat ja hier auch eigentlich ein Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem langsam wird sie sich da nicht durchsetzen kann an
Deichmann die einzige Logik für für Ostseeufer ist es doch irgendwie so wie in Österreich auch mit der AFD und war mal zu koalieren und in anderes Excel Szenario gibt's doch da gerade nicht ich weiß Bayern Wahl und so und da hat man Angst davor und gab nach rechts aufschließen zu müssen
aber ich ich ich bin sehr gespannt auf diese Bayern Wahl weil ich glaube nicht dass das funktionieren wird.
Nee das wird nicht funktionieren meiner wenn man den Prognosen glauben mag wird das auf jeden Fall das schlechteste Wahlergebnis der CSU je hatte deshalb wird somit 35% gerechnet.
In einem Land wo früher hat Bayern so in der Regel irgendwas zwischen 55 und 60% abgezogen hat
und naja lustigerweise könnte es dann natürlich auf eine Konstellation hinauslaufen wo sie mit der AFD zusammen regieren könnte.
Ja das kann sich natürlich nicht erlauben wenn wenn sich erlauben sind
die komplett tot wenn sie sich das nicht erlauben müssen sich trotzdem nach einer Regierungs Alternative umschauen das kann eigentlich nur eine Koalition aus
CSU Grünen und SPD werden es ist wirklich abenteuerlich man muss gucken wie die FDP da abschneidet aber das wird auf jeden Fall
schlimm und was Haus Seehof also generell so reitet das fragen sich glaube ich alle.
Was die SPD hier die SPD stellt sich halt immer wieder so hin mit naja
Deutschland zuerst und wir müssen ja für stabile Verhältnisse sorgen und wenn wir es nicht machen dann dann machen Sie anderen und die machen sehr viel schlechter als wir und wir setzen ja auch noch irgendwas durch und gucke mal wer mir irgendwie auch eine kluge Justizministerin ist hinter
mag ja im Detail auch alles stimmen dass sie das irgendwie gut meinen aber gut gemeint ist halt nicht gut gemacht und das Problem ist dass sie halt im Kern eine Koalition Stützen wo als solche lunis rumlaufen wie im Horst Seehofer
und das ganze schlecht einfach seit Jahren passiert schon seit Jahrzehnten
diese ganze Opposition Situation man warten dass der letzten Legislaturperiode schon zum Zeitpunkt des Untersuchungsausschusses
rund um die Geheimdienste das wär's mit Linken und Grünen sondern Miniatur Opposition zu tun hat sie sich eben diesem
diese Übermacht der großen Koalition gegenüber konfrontiert sah und da überhaupt nichts ans Licht kommt und die ganze parlamentarische Arbeit als Zufahrt
also die Meinung darüber ob die SPD halt mehr aufrecht mal ihrem Untergang entgegen laufen sollte als ich schleichen von dem Einholen zulassen gehen auseinander.
Die jungen Leute in der SPD sind definitiv auch anders als die alten aber das jetzt die neue Personal consolation mit Nahles und Scholz hier nennenswerte Fortschritte erzielt hat
das sehe ich noch nicht und das abzuwarten was hier jetzt noch passiert aber
diese Woche hier mit Maßen ins Innenministerium das damit machen sich auf jeden Fall keine Freude und ich glaube die Diskussion wird zu schnell dich.
Ich hoffe es also im Grunde solche Leute irgendwie mit.
Der Hattinger einstellungen einen in Sicherheitsapparat zu haben es brandgefährlich
und es gibt da halt auch überhaupt keine Selbstreinigungsprozess also vor allem solche Leute haben ja eine enorme Wirkung dann auch in den Apparat hinein was die Auswahl von Personal Beförderungen interne Richtlinien betrifft
Anteil der ist dann genau der Bereich wo es überhaupt keine Kontrolle gibt weil vielleicht hat man dann hier und da ein Whistleblower aber das sind dann auch die Leute die hat die Beförderung nicht bekommen haben wirkliche Handhabe hat man dann nicht
An und wenn man irgendwie meint dass dies der Sicherheitsapparat
auch in die Gesellschaft hineinwirken sollen der gewisse Werte ja auch im Umgang gerade mit sozialen Brennpunkten hochhalten muss dann es ist ganz wichtig da die richtigen Leute zu haben ich meine
es wird auch so lächerlich gesagt als Polizei ist größte Menschenrechtsorganisation der Welt aber das sollte ja Anspruch sein
nur mit solchen Leuten wird es niemals passieren.
Ja also die Hoffnung schwindet in Deutschland aber wir haben ja noch Österreich.
KAG.
Ihr ihr rettet uns oder bei euch würde sowas nie passieren weight.
Wo ist es ja wir sind da schon weiter nicht im guten Sinn.
Schauen wir in die Zukunft schauen wir nach Österreich.
Ja also ich kann euch nicht viel optimistisches versprechen aber ich glaube es sind ein paar Sachen drin die wo man drüber wenigstens lachen kann und zwar werde ich gerne
Didi bvt-affäre in Österreich kurz in ihrer Chronologie aufarbeiten
diese bvt-affäre wird gerade im Rahmen eines Untersuchungsausschusses eines parlamentarischen in Österreich
behandelt und ist ein wirkliches Gustostück was auch sehr anschlussfähig ist glaube ich an so die Maßen Debatte und an Geheimdienste und und AFD generell.
Muss erstmal sagen was ist BVT.
Das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung ist der österreichische Verfassungsschutz
A und das ist Bundesamt weil.
Es gibt ja halt auch wie in Deutschland der Bundesamt und Landesämter aber wir sprechen hier uns einfach zumachen eigentlich bei pvt stellen euch vor der Verfassungsschutz.
Diese Behörde wurde 2002 eingerichtet
von der ersten schwarzplan Bundesregierung die wir hatten also die schwarze konservative und blaue was in Deutschland die AFD ist wurde also gegründet nach den Terroranschlägen von nine-eleven als
Polizeibehörde mit Geheimnis Befugnissen
Geheimdienst Befugnissen also es ist sowas wie ein Inlandsgeheimdienst der nach innen gerichtet nachgefahren sucht
der du hast auch auf Gehrung für abstrakte gefahren Bilder machen kann also nicht Verdacht abhängig ermitteln sondern einfach mal so wir schauen uns jetzt alle schienen an.
In die Richtung
darf die Behörde tätig werden sie ist aber trotzdem eine Polizeibehörde und das heißt wenn die Straftaten sieht dass sie nicht wegschauen sondern muss diese dann auch verfolgen und zur Anzeige bringen.
Seid ihr dabei.
Hintergasse bemerkenswert dass es die sozusagen auch erst seit 2002 gab also komm hattet ihr euch so sein die schneller Nazis in die Regierung eingetreten Garbsen erstmal neuen geheim die.
Genau als ich weiß jetzt nicht ob es irgendeine Vorläufer Behörde gab aber ich glaube fast dass das dann innerhalb von anderen Polizeistruktur man diese nach innen gerichtete Aufgabe hatte wir haben sonst noch eine 2 Geheimdienst habe diesen beide militärisch,
das sah ja das nachrichten an was nach außen schaut und das heeresabwehramt dass die Sicherheit von militärischen Anlagen sicherstellen soll
aber ja das bevor die war schon so irgendwie wir Leistungs jetzt mein Inlandsgeheimdienst weil Terror und
ist es ist zwar unter einer schwarz-blauen Bundesregierung
geschaffen worden 2002 war aber bis 2017 immer unter der Führung von schwarzen
Innenminister Nora Ennest Ministerinnen wir hatten da auch zwei Frauen in der Linie aber war zu sagen immer
eine hatte da eine schwarze Hausmacht ja dass man dazu wissen soll in Österreich ist die Polizei sehr stark politisiert
was im Richterberuf undenkbar wer wer Richter in Österreich ist darf sich nicht parteipolitisch betätigen das ist verpönt und man findet auch keine Richter die irgendwie in.
Politischen Ämtern sind jene Polizei ist das leider gang und gäbe dort gibt es über die Polizeigewerkschaften die alle verschiedene Parteien zugehörig sind eine starke.
Parteipolitische Bindung und es gibt auch recht viele
Polizisten Polizisten die sogar aktive Ämter haben z.b. im Gemeinderat oder in anderen Funktionen wir haben auch Nationalratsabgeordnete die bei der Polizei sind und die Polizei ist auch in den letzten Jahrzehnten immer
blauer geworden also immer mehr in Richtung der FPÖ gewandert mit außen aber das BVT da waren immer die schwarzen die Konservativen in der
Überzahl das so nur zur Toilette sina ist Ausgangssituation und dann wir haben.
Herbst 2017 also letztes Jahr
da wurden Vorwürfe gegen das BVT erhoben es gab da ein sogenanntes konvolut von einem
anonymen Verfasser dass in einer 34 seitigen untereinander 39 seitigen Variante an verschiedene.
Oppositionspolitiker Journalisten an die Staatsanwaltschaft geschickt wurde das ist so kursiert und ich habe
das selber mal durchgelesen es ist irgendwie sehr.
Widerwille Räuberpistolen die in diesem Konvolut drinnen stehen das geht von Korruption Übergriffe.
S******** in Dienst Geldwäsche da werden alle möglichen Vorwürfe erhoben und auch Mitglieder des BVT namentlich genannt als die sind dafür verantwortlich
und es gibt zwei Vorwürfe in diesem Konvolut Didi irgendwie heraus Star
AAA einmal die die nicht Löschung von Daten eines espionaje Anwalts
der in der causa Aliyev tätig war Aliyev ist glaube ich kasachisches Ausgestoßener der dortigen Regierung und da gabs dann irgendwie auch eine riesige Skandal um Gerichtsprozess dazu der Anwalt der diesen Menschen vertreten hat
über den wurden scheinbar unrechtmäßig Daten gespeichert
aber das prominente Beispiel war das den BVT vorgegeben vorgeworfen wurde
Embassy nordkoreanische Pass Rohlinge an Südkorea weitergegeben haben Kürze Hintergrund Österreich hat eine sehr
große Staatsdruckerei die schon seit Jahrhunderten in der im Bereich der sicherheitsdruckerei tätig ist also bei uns wird sehr viel Geld gedruckt und auch andere.
Die man lieber nicht gefälscht wissen will wie zwei Spielerpässe und das.
Nordkoreanische Regime hat 200.000 Pässe in Österreich bestellt und weil das war nur 200000 wahrscheinlich lassen sich nicht so viel Leute sind dann draußen auf jeden Fall.
Artmann.
Dann im Zuge der der Olympischen Winterspiele 2018 dir in Südkorea passiert sind an das südkoreanische verschieben Regierung Regierung sagt man in dem Fall einige
Pass Rohlinge weitergegeben wohlgemerkt diese Rohlinge sind eben nur so lang groß da ist,
Passnummer drauf da ist kein Name drauf also die kann man jetzt nicht dafür verwenden um damit irgendwie Agenten aus zu starten unter der falschen Identität
sondern diese Baden dem Vernehmen nach einfach deswegen an Südkorea weitergegeben weil.
Das dafür dient dass man dann im Zucker wieder Spieler kontrollieren kann ob die nordkoreanischen Pässe echt sind oder nur Fälschungen.
Also quasi so als Vorlage für wie sieht ein echter eigentlich aus.
Aber dieses Konvolut ist zirkuliert und kam im Zuge dessen auch an Sonn alliston und es gab die ersten Medienberichte die wirklich auch so bist du.
Warte mal kurz dein Einstieg ja schon geil es gab da auch s******** aber es gibt andere Sachen die hilft Dir wirklich berichtenswert sind finde ich ja jetzt schon mal ein bisschen schade Österreich macht die Pässe für Nordkorea.
Aber liefert sie dann ohne Nordkorea zu fragen an Südkorea an die Geheimdienste ok.
Und das hat auch die österreichischen Medien wie gesagt die s******* ist war nicht jemand die standen da genauso.
Das ist doch ganz normal sie ist heute Österreich.
Ja das ist das Zeug gewisse Skurrilität und Morbidität findest du schon auch in Österreich das.
Ich bin nicht überrascht aber ich blicke ja in die Zukunft ich schaue nach Österreich.
Ja also wir zuletzt gebaut hat mit dem Vergewaltigung auf der Straße in Wien das ist ja nicht so wir haben Kultur dafür abend eben weniger Übergriffe aber auf jeden Fall
es gab Medienberichte darüber dass.
Hesse weitergegeben wurden da war irgendwie das bei soll dahinter das war für die Medien attraktives Thema und dies gab die ersten Berichte das angeblich da
Pässe weitergegeben worden und das Innenministerium schickt man sofort ein Dementi raus es gibt eine.
Presseaussendung des Innenressort hast die immer noch immernoch nachlesen kann aus dem September 2017 wo dann eben gesagt wird dass es ein ganz regulärer Vorgang,
AS ich zitiere es ist über es überrascht das übliche und regulärer Vorgänger auf Grundlage anonyme Skandalisierung and das ist diese Pamphlet und weiter nicht konkretisierte Behauptungen
in vorliegender Form Gegenstand der Bericht Erkennung
anerkannte Medien sein können nach Informationen des Innenministeriums stand die Behauptung aus anonymen Schreiben die in anderen Zusammenhang längst widerlegt worden sind
Warum anonymen Anschuldigungen die sich in manchen Teilen in einer sachlichen Überprüfung entziehen in anderen Teilen längst widerlegt sind dermaßen Raum zugestanden wird.
Keine seriösen Betrachtung nicht nachvollziehbar also Innenministerium sagt
nichts zu sehen gehen Sie weiter wir geben hier ganz oft so pass Rohlinge weiter an das ist ein regulärer Vorgang weil wir eben als Ort wo viele Pässe gedruckt werden das was ein Pass ist
einfach weitergeben und das dient eigentlich nur der Sicherheit des Betroffenen Landes.
Das war über alles noch unter der schwarzen Führung des Innenministeriums in der rot-schwarzen Bundesregierung wie damals schon in ihren letzten Metern war dann war aval
und wir haben dann am 17. Dezember eine neue schwarzblaue Bundesregierung bekommen.
Und diesmal war es sowas in ziemliches Novum war dass man Däninnen Apparat Seite Sicherheitsbehörden der Film.
Fahrplan Regierungspartei übergeben Hearts sowohl innen wie auch Verteidigungs Resort ging an die FPÖ die eVB hat nur noch.
Justiz Resort und da ist jetzt jetzt noch mal wichtig sich die Person des FBI Innenministers anzuschauen das ist ein gewisser Herr
Herbert Kickl wir verlinken da auch immer nette Berichte über ihn aber es gibt hier ist groß geworden als Redenschreiber
von Jörg Haider und als solcher gilt er als Hirn der FPÖ also das Brain hinter der Operation und er ist vor allem eben durch so
coole Slogans bekannt geworden wie daham statt Islam Pummerin statt Muezzin Pummerin ist die.
Kühe im Stephansdom im größten Kirchturm in Österreich und auch ein Einsatz der
ihm zugeschrieben wird der glaube ich auch so gesagt hat ist wie kann einer der Ariel heißt so viel Dreck am Stecken haben und das ist bezogen auf Arielle Musik ans dem Vorsitzenden der israelische Kultusgemeinde
am dieser Mensch ist aktuell Innenminister in Österreich und noch nicht zurückgetreten was ist in der Folge passiert.
Aber wir bleiben doch eben die bei den Vorläufen ist es wird bald spannend aber am 20 februar 2018
Essen in diesem Jahr der Vertrag des Chefs des DVDs des Verfassungsschutzes dem Herrn Peter Gridling mit dem ich
natürlich schon einiges zu tun hatte.
Politischen Auseinandersetzungen dessen Vertrag lief aus und wurde aber schon vom vorherigen Amtsinhaber von dem schwarzen Innenminister wiederbestellt.
Aber eigentlich nur sozusagen die Formalia zu erledigen dass er eben Abend bleiben darf waldmarie natürlich das.
Eigene Leute in den wichtigen Positionen bleiben und das macht nur noch bevor die Wahl.
Passiert und wie war die Chef Petra Keding wurde mit einer sogenannten.
Bestallungsurkunde ist es keine Bestellungsurkunde ist es wirklich eine Bestallungsurkunde an einer Stunde halten Österreich die die wurde sozusagen schon von Bundespräsident Alexander van der Bellen unterschrieben.
Und eigentlich nur zurückgeschickt ans Innenministerium dass die eigentlich dann dem Peter Gridling als sozusagen du bist es wieder hier ist offiziell nur noch mal was du eh schon weißt übergeben werden und diese Übergabe
fand nicht statt und 20 Februar kann das Dokument vom Bundespräsidenten im Innenministerium an und ver
blieb dann auch dort gleichzeitig im Februar 2018 Carmen 4 anonymer,
zeigen inzwischen weiß man gern identität damals war sie noch anonym die sich bei der Staatsanwaltschaft gemeldet haben sie geben diese Zeiten Garten an um ihr Leben zu fürchten.
M&A home sehr schwere Vorwürfe gegen das bvta dieser Zeugen wurden wie wir heute wissen
begleitet von dem höchsten Beamten im Innenministerium und engsten Vertrauten von Herbert Kickl Peter Goldgruber.
Hatte der hat dich bei der Hand genommen und zur Staatsanwaltschaft begleitet und.
Diese Vorwürfe die darum wurden drehten sich halt eben rund um das Wasser schon aus dem Pamphlet kennen dass es hier eben eine nicht vollzogene Datenlöschung gab
das ist ein eine Zusammenarbeit,
der dem südkoreanischen südkoreanischen Regierung gab und das insgesamt hier halt einfach
BVT Gefahr im Verzug passiert und deswegen hat ein
hat man am 27 Februar 2018.
Bei der Wirtschafts und Korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft hat eine Hausdurchsuchung im BVT angeordnet,
sozusagen wir gehen jetzt hier in den Inlandsgeheimdienst der Auftrag war die Sicherstellung sämtlicher Unterlagen Daten und elektronischer
Daten mit Informationen zu den Sachverhalten das inkludierte auch E-Mails SMS und sonstige da
Grundlage für die Durchsuchung sind neben der passend weitergeben eben die Vorwürfe der unterlassenen Datenlöschung.
Am und um 22 Uhr dreißig Uhr hat dann ein journalrichter übers Telefon diese Hausdurchsuchung.
Gestartet diese Haus.
Journalrichter ist mehr weniger die arme Sau oft der gerade jüngste Richter der's geschafft hat nicht rechtzeitig den Dienstplan zu beanstanden der.
An der Stelle dann sozusagen für Dinge die richterliche Genehmigung.
Was soll der der der Richter dujour sozusagen.
Das ist da wo deine richterliche Genehmigung brauchst eben bei gewissen Überwachungsmaßnahmen oder eben auch bei Hausdurchsuchungen
da braucht halt immer einen Richter der Notfall noch wach ist und ja oder nein sagen kann in der Ameisen Fan Sachen die dann ja weil das nein müssen Sie schriftlich begründen.
Dazu haben wir das ja.
Also die sogenannte stand-bidet Bewilligung großes Problem aber das kam hier halt eben auch so kams dazu.
Das ein Richter und eine Staatsanwaltschaft
diese Genehmigung gaben auf sozusagen starkes Drängen des Innenministeriums das Justizministerium hat später angegeben von alldem nichts gewusst zu haben und das glaube ich ihnen sogar auch
es kann dann eben zu dieser Hausdurchsuchung im Hauptgebäude des BVT das ist dann
nicht so interessant für die deutschen Geheimdienste also BND und und deutscher Verfassungsschutz sind da da schon irgendwie um den Faktor 30 bis 100 größer aber immer noch irgendwie ein recht imposantes Gebäude mit hohen Mauern.
AMR und da kannst du hast Du suchen in drinnen und auch in den Privatwohnungen von einigen BVT Beamtinnen,
diese Hausdurchsuchungen wurden durchgeführt von der Eingreiftruppe gegen Straßenkriminalität.
Lustigerweise auch eine Polizeibehörde die von einem FPÖ-Politiker geleitet wird Wolfgang Preißler der für die FPÖ.
Die haben dann in normaler Zivilkleidung mit verdeckten Waffen sich Zutritt zu diesen Gebäuden verschafft und bei diesem Grazien.
Dokumente und Speicher Träger mitgenommen onmaz es gibt Streit darüber ob das jetzt nur irgendwie 9 g Barren oder 4000gb,
Ausruf von den Größenordnungen reden wir auch wirklich jede Art von Speicher Träger auch ob die jetzt in die religiöse Weise damit zu tun haben oder nicht dass ich jedes telefoniere SD-Karte und alles unter anderem wurde.
Auch ab und hat auch becherträger sichergestellt von der Abteilungsleiterin für extremismusbekämpfung obwohl diese nur als
Feigen in diesem Verfahren geführt wird und hier ist zu sagen dass in Österreich.
Burschenschaften und die identitäre Bewegung die der FPÖ sehr nahe stehen
Arm von unter die Beobachtung des Verfassungsschutzes fallen also die wurden in den letzten Verfassungsschutz berichten immer mit eigenen.
Ausgeführt und es gibt ja einer Beobachtung weil dieser eben.
Bares was uns vereint liche Gruppierungen in Österreich zum Teil eingestuft werden gerade bei der identitären Bewegung waren diese Einstufung glaube ich es 2017.
Achtung bitte 2018 auch noch nicht aufgehoben Felder übernatürliche in diese ganze Welt hinein und dieser abteilungsleiterinnen ins Referat für extremismusbekämpfung hatte da halt eben auch wirklich die.
Blackened Arten der kompletten Beobachtung der rechtsextremen Szene in Österreich der letzten Jahrzehnte bei sich als diese sichergestellt wurden.
Die Begründung für die Erzieher ist wieso hat man da jetzt irgendwie mit Gefahr im Verzug unbedingt diese Daten
jetzt so mitnehmen müssen und nicht einfach über Amtshilfe über eine Weisung des Innenministers sichergestellt.
Dieses an Waldsee auch gelöscht wurden und dann du du du du hast sie nicht deine Daten tot gehalten die Begründung
der Regierung in diesem Fall ist es hätte ja die Möglichkeit einer Fernlöschung gegeben.
Und dann hätten wir dieses Verbrechen der der der unrechtmäßigen Speicherung von Daten der nicht mehr aufgehen können
in dem schon laufenden BVT Untersuchungsausschuss der
die Woche wieder geparkt hat hat dann auch ein BVT Techniker ausgesagt dass das absoluter Humbug ist weil natürlich ist das ein protokolliertes Dateisystem sodass sozusagen alles was in den Speicher Träger des BVBs abgespeichert ist
dort nicht einfach so gelöscht werden kannst und jeder Zugriff jede Änderung und natürlich ihre Löschung wird revisionssicher protokolliert.
So dass du auch im Nachhinein.
Genau das wird nicht gelöscht sondern.
Antonov dann irgendwann wirklich gelöscht hätten aber du weißt dass Person X zurzeit. Y Datenbestand Z zugegriffen hat und diese Protokolldaten bleiben erhalten auch wenn die Daten selbst irgendwann schon noch mal gelöscht.
So das ist.
Alter Falter was heißt hier muss mal kurz zusammenzufassen also angezeigt also.
MMI Terror para geht los Österreich gleich ganz vorne braucht man auch man Verfassungsschutz weil
sonst werde ich mir sicher wird gegründet ist aber jahrelang von der ÖVP kontrolliert kaum reiten die blauen da ein
dreht sich alles und es werden.
Ja Hausdurchsuchung inszeniert könnte man fast sagen um einfach an Daten der Beobachtung der rechten Szene zu kommen.
Genau das ist wo ist die Kurzzusammenfassung von dem was im Raum steht
alles passiert eben am 8. am 27 Februar nach dem 20. Februar war's dann schon als die Hausdurchsuchung passiert
und am 3. März oder nicht lange danach sind die ersten Informationen über diese Razzia an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt und auch dass einige BVT
Mitarbeiter suspendiert wurden ihnen wird Datenmissbrauch und die Veruntreuung von Geldern vorgeworfen
und ja unter den Beschuldigten ist eben auch Verfassungsschutz Chef Peter Gridling und genauso diesem Zeitpunkt verschwindet er sehr gut getaktet auf Urlaub.
Wie gesagt sein Vertrag läuft mit 20 März aus und seine Bestallungsurkunde hat er nicht bekommen
am 8. März ist die die schon alle schon brodelt schaltet sich dann das Justizminister Ministerium 1 und
will mehr von der Wirtschafts und Korruptionsstaatsanwaltschaft Wien Wissen über diese Ermittlungen gegen BVT Beamte.
Arm und man fragt sich halt eben genau wieso diese FPÖ.
IPhone von einem FPÖ Politiker und Gewerkschafter geführte Polizeitruppe für Straßenkriminalität diese Hausdurchsuchung gemacht hat.
A und wieso gerade eben auch diese Daten Referatsleiterin
sextremismus beschlagnahmt werde obwohl die gar nicht beschuldigt ist am 9. März gibt's dann schon die ersten Forderungen von Oppositionsparteien als wird der nationale Sicherheitsrat einberufen dass du ein Gremium ist um.
Über sicherheit zu reden und meistens passiert da nicht viel es gibt die ersten Sondersitzungen im Parlament der Bundespräsident Alexander van der Bellen.
Erwartet sich eine Aufklärung der Affäre.
Unser Innenminister Herbert Kickl sagt wieso gehst du hier auf das war doch hier ganz normaler und Zitat lupenreine hausdurchsung.
Es gibt dann schon im März erste Versuche der SPÖ eine Untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen hier ist sozusagen das erst seit dieser Legislaturperiode es in Österreich einen Untersuchungsausschuss als
Minderheitenrecht gibt davor hat man dafür immer eine Regierungsmehrheit gebraucht das österreichischer Parlamentarismus ist sowieso ein sch
traurige Angelegenheit aber wir haben auch keinen wissenschaftlichen Dienst und wir haben viel Geld für Mitarbeiter und erst seit kurzen haben wir überhaupt die Möglichkeit dass die Opposition auf Gehrung von politischer Verantwortung.
In einem Untersuchungsausschuss fahren kann und auch das wenn die Regierung nichts zu stimmt das ist Aufklärung gib.
Erst seit dieser Legislaturperiode.
Das war mit ein Ding was er dann seine letzten Metern 2017 raus verhandelt wurde und das gleich gibt's jetzt aber.
Und wurde hier halt zum ersten Mal benutzt die SPÖ so Firma leidigen Wegner gescheitert aber hat es dann geschafft dass sie sich mit allen anderen drei Oppositionsparteien auf so einen Antrag für einen Untersuchungsausschuss.
Geeinigt hat und der Untersuchungsausschuss ist jetzt eben schon konstituiert seit April und Tag der PC glaube ich schon sieben Mal.
Am
Und seit der Untersuchungsausschuss konzentriert ist dann eben auch diese Suspendierung von BVT Chef Peter Gridling aufgehoben worden.
Der ist jetzt wieder im Amt.
Aus Akten vermerkten Gitter vor der EM Edition hat noch kurz versucht ihn wieder loszuwerden auf anderem Wege ist damit aber gescheitert und Peter Gridling wie das so üblich ist als Beamter ist man immer I da dabei ist.
Timken Schüttorf vorzubereiten und ist jetzt betraut worden mit der Reform des BVT von Innenminister Herbert Kickl denk hab noch versucht hat loszuwerden und es gibt für eingerichtet dass das.
Die jetzt noch in dieser Regierung zum echten Geheimdienst umgebaut werden soll seine Trennung vom Polizeidienst und Geheimdienst war gar nicht so schlecht aber.
Unter diesen Vorzeichen ist dass er trotzdem nicht dass man sich wünscht
diese ganze Haus durchsuchen jetzt immer noch im Untersuchungsausschuss aufgearbeitet fährt wurde am 28 kust vom Oberlandesgericht Wien.
Für rechtswidrig erklärt also deren gesagt das gesamte Ding hätte niemals passieren dürfen und war combat unverhältnismäßig.
Haben und was immer schon im Raum stand aber jetzt auch schon belegt ist natürlich in Geheimdienst der unteren Lander sind im Regen Datenaustausch wir haben das unter den ganzen Snowden Enthüllungen ja schon.
Sehr massiv diskutiert gerade da wo die Daten der eigenen oder fremden Bevölkerung mit freien Geheimdiensten getauscht werden kann das hoch kritisch sein
ben ben Geheimdienste kooperieren aber prinzipiell will man schauen dass die nicht jeder das Rad neu erfinden sondern miteinander reden und sich über Gefahren austauschen.
Genau von dieser Art von Austausch ist Österreich jetzt scheinbar ausgeschlossen es gibt zumindest Warnungen dass wir aus der sogenannten Berner Gruppe
rausgeworfen wurden dass es so ein Club der Chefs von europäischen und anderer Geheimdienste zum Austausch von Daten und Strategien.
Und insgesamt muss man hier sagen dass Österreich inzwischen wirklich so als.
Wurmfortsatz von Putins Russland gilt immer mehr Österreich war immer.
Nicht klar aus oder weißt zugeteilt weil wir nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ja als neutrales und und und Block freies Land geschaffen wurden aber wir hatten letztens Putin.
Auf der Hochzeit unserer Außenministerin erwartet geladen als privater Gast.
Und die einzigen zugelassenen Journalisten waren von Russia Today und unsere brilliante e-nomine Außenministerin
hat auch mit Putin getanzt und wir sind Österreich üblich ist dann einen Knicks gemacht also es gibt Bilder wo unsere Außenministerin verboten kniet vor der wunderbaren österreichischen Berg Szenerie also ich kann mir schon gut vorstellen dass jetzt auf
und all dieser Gegebenheiten Österreich sehr kritisch gesehen wird im weltweiten Sicherheitsapparat,
nein Gustostück in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss der die ganze Zeit Park gibt's viele Teile der Sitzungen wo Medien zugelassen sind aber es gibt doch sozusagen,
niemanden jetzt innerhalb der FPÖ der es ist Essen gibt
SPD-Abgeordnete die im Ausschuss sitzen natürlich die haben sich aber bis jetzt eigentlich mit ihren Statements gar nicht so zimperlich gezeigt und sogar das Innenministerium teilweise kritisiert
an aber das Innenministerium stellt sich eben da nicht drinnen
und er ist gab es schon einmal einen Fall bei einer Fachreferentin des Innenministeriums sich mit einem gefälschten Presseausweis auch schon alliston hinterm Medienraum gesetzt hat um genau rauszufinden.
Basti Zeugen.
Denn jetzt genau Aussagen über das Innenministerium das ist aber raus aufgeflogen und sie wurde rausgeworfen aber so das ist das Niveau auf dem hier auch operiert wird.
Oh Gott mann mann mann mann mann.
Sparkonto Aussterben also um vielleicht in die Analyse zu gehen das ganze ist natürlich der Versuch einer einer um Förderaktion jetzt wo die blauen endlich den Sicherheitsberater über haben wollen Sie.
Die Kontrolle dort bekommen das ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen die FPÖ.
Der Großteil der gewählten Vertreter von FPÖ in in Nationalrat im Europaparlament und auch in den Landesparlamenten stammen aus Burschenschaften
Burschenschaften in Österreich gibt auch konservativer die er christlich sind und eben aber schlagende Burschenschaft.
Sehr sehr recht orientiert sind und gerade aus diesem Milieu rekrutiert die FPÖ einen Großteil ihres Personals
nun ist aber gerade in den letzten Jahren gab es immer wieder Affären rund um diese Burschenschaft
ich erinnere an die Andy Liederbuch Affäre wo Liederbücher der Burschenschaften gefunden wurden die den den Holocaust verleugnen die das NS-Regime glorifizieren mit Zitaten wie kommt
ich esse zitiert aus dem Kopf kommt wir schaffen das ihr Teutonen wir schaffen die siebte million damit es hat Gemeinde sechs Millionen Juden im
Weltkriegs ermordet wurden und das hat zurücktreten von von Spitzenkandidaten der FPÖ geführt im im niederösterreichischen.
Landeswahl Kampf.
Der Betroffene Politiker ist übrigens gestern wieder ins ins Amt gekommen Udo landbauer aber hier gibt's sozusagen ein Spannungsverhältnis darauf will ich hinaus zwischen
der schwarzen Ihnen
Politik die die durch Asien der Minderheit ist in insgesamt in der Politik aber die sich halt doch irgendwie einen Brief vom Verfassungsschutz
zugehörig fühlt das durchaus kritisch auf gewisse Rechte Teile in Österreich blickt und diese rechten Teile haben wir zuzusagen aber dank Sebastian Kurz der Koalition
mit dieser Partei geführt hat genau diese Sicherheitsbehörden
unterstellt bekommen und anstatt immer das üblicherweise macht Leute Weg zu loben und all diese
langdielen im schwarzen Kanten im Sicherheitsapparat einfach
Staatssekretär Zimmer oder irgendwo hin Weg zu loben hat man sie sozusagen versucht über einen sehr brachialen Wege nach Hausdurchsuchung
zu entmachten und das ist halt komplett nach hinten losgegangen natürlich es gibt
dickwach Rücktrittsforderungen an Innenminister Herbert Kickl von der Opposition und von andererseits.
Und das ist leider nicht passiert bis jetzt das muss man aber immer wieder fordern wir haben leider in Österreich eine sehr geringe Rücktritts kulturist
Politiker können sich in Österreich sehr viel leisten bevor es persönliche Konsequenzen gibt.
Wir haben eine sehr politisierte Polizei was an sich schon ein Problem ist insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund.
Das jetzt im Watt Regierungsprogramm massiv in der Polizei aufgestockt wird als es kommen 11009
Planstellen für die Polizei das heißt ein Drittel des kompletten Apparats wird jetzt gerade neu besetzt dass es eine sehr langfristige Änderung
das sind alles Beamten die haben Verträge fast auf Lebenszeit.
Was sieht daran irgendwie die FPÖ kann einerseits nicht regieren gleichzeitig die denken langfristig also Befürchtung steht im Raum dass sie das Lernen.
Übrigens es gibt doch schöner reden von FPÖ AFD Gruppierungen wir werden da auch wieder ein Video verlinken das genau da FPÖ Politiker die der AFD Tipps.
Geben zeigt bitte bitte und an sich.
Dieser Skandal aus Datenschutz respektive ich meine wir müssen das noch mal auf die ursprünglichen Vorwürfe eingehen ja.
Warte warte mal kurz Nummer sozusagen seine Rücktritt Situation ich meine ein Innenminister der quasi sein eigenes.
Untergebene Amt demfall Geheimdienst
mit dem Ziel den Chef abzusetzen mit illegalen Hausdurchsuchung überzieht das reicht den Bundeskanzler nicht um diesen Innenminister zu entlassen.
Es gibt von Sebastian Kurz eine einzige Reaktion zu diesem ganzen Thema und das ist dieselbe Reaktion die Wolfgang Schüssel der Kanzler der letzten schwarzblond Bundesregierung auch schon perfektioniert hat.
Schweigt er schafft es dieses komplette Thema.
Auszusitzen er äußert sich nicht dazu das ist über Wochen in den Medien die gesamte Opposition trommelt alle möglichen Kanten und Stimmen im Land rufen dazu auf dass das wirklich nicht sein kann Bundespräsident fordert Aufklärung und Wand,
unter Kanzler schweigt und an die die ÖVP ist perfekter drin message control zu zu betreiben
haben und das erwürgt auch den politischen Diskurs in gewisser Weise weil man es halt nicht schafft durchzukommen weil man es nicht schafft dass man eine inhaltliche Debatte führt und dazu kommt leider auch noch.
Da blicken wir in Österreich sehr neidisch auf deutsche Medien bei uns in Österreich am Journalisten nicht die Haltung des jetzt wirklich auch mal.
Auf eine Antwort auf eine Frage beharren.
Dass sie wirklich auch mal sagen sie haben meine Frage nicht beantwortet oder das ist ein das ist Blödsinn was Sie sagen sondern leider kommt der Bundeskanzler mit diesem Ding durch.
Am
Also ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen dass durch eine besonders ausgeprägte kulturell entwickelt hat in diesem Bereich aber es mag weniger weniger scheiße sein als nächster.
Estenfeld auf.
Also ja kommt wir doch zurück zu den eigentlichen Vorwürfen weil ich will ja noch herausstreichen dieses Pamphlet
es ursprünglich schon zirkuliert markante Alters es gab ein Dementi das kann man immer noch einsehen das Innenministerium sagt er das ist alles im ganz üblicher Vorgang.
Antenne mich gibt's nichts zu sehen und das haben alle akzeptiert und gut was und dann hat man diese Suppe aufgekocht und das eben bis zu Hausdurchsuchung eskaliert indem.
Höchste Beamte des Innenministeriums Zeugen an der Hand nimmt und zum zum Staatsanwalt führt.
Dieselskandal über die unrechtmäßig gespeicherten Daten noch mal kurz aus datenschutzsicht natürlich ich würde mir das hin und wieder Würmchen das,
das wäre so wirklich mal in günstig über illegale Datenspeicherung in reden da gibt es recht viel was kanalisierbar wäre wir haben uns hier trotzdem taktisch zurückgehalten weil wir.
Bavaria datenschutzorganisation sind jetzt nicht Erfüllungsgehilfen zu RTK und dem was hier sonst noch ab.
Aber das ist ein Pitch Schlag an den wir sie messen werden nur hier geht halt eigentlich um was anderes.
Auch diese eingeschränkte Kooperation mit Geheimdiensten wie gesagt wenn Geheimdienste Daten tauschen Überbevölkerung oder Sicht.
Veeam Ringtausch mit NSA und Deutschland ja laut Snowden angeblich üblich oder mit den Franzosen die Franzosen überwachen die deutschen die Deutschen bewachen die Franzosen und danach werden die Daten gedauert
am das ist definitiv abzulehnen gleichzeitig dass man Österreich dann keine Informationen mehr weiter gibt es gibt ja auch
rechten Terrorismus und ich würde mich wundern wenn es einen nso.hu in Österreich von der von nicht gäbe bei uns brennen keiner
asylheime aber andere Rechte Kriminalität ist sehr stark im steigen und da
darf ich schon dass wir jetzt irgendwie eingeschränkt sind und auch immer blinder werden gegenüber genau diese Art von Gewalt die halt.
Hier auch immer mehr in den Staatsapparat sich rein sickert die sowieso im Parlament und der politischen Debatte.
Nicht mehr geächtet wurde oder von immer mehr kleinen Teilen der Gesellschaft geächtet wurde aber jetzt halt auch wirklich an ein Status Quo wird der sehr langfristig versucht diesen Staat.
Ja und nur ganz kurz Wie heißt epicenter works haben 2015 als die Rechtsgrundlage für das BVT reformiert wurde genau von diesen Sachen gerade
hat das polizeiliche staatsschutzgesetz gemacht wurde haben wir ganz laut getrommelt für
mehr Kontrolle des BVT für mehr Transparenz und mehr Transparenz hätte hier auf jeden Fall auch geholfen um auch so einen Eindruck schonmal vorzubeugen
das jetzt Sachen ganz im Argen laufen in dem Untersuchungsausschuss geht auch explizit um diese Hausdurchsuchung.
Um diese Skandal der jetzt unter der blauen Herrschaft des Innenministeriums passiert ist aber auch.
Die ganzen schwarzen Skandale die die FPÖ jetzt als als als wahrscheinlich fadenscheinige Begründung hergeholt hat aber das nimmt man jetzt auch zum Anlass um sich näher anzuschauen was denn in diesen
15 Jahren schwarzer Herrschaft des BVT alles passiert es so wieder.
Gute Güte.
Dann sollten wir vielleicht mal um das auch mal abzurunden an der Stelle ist er ab und zu immer mal ganz gut war aus unseren status update zu
machen Wort mal so auf die Situation der österreichischen Politik zuschauen österreichischer derzeit ja derzeit die Ratspräsidentschaft inne in Europa
wer das nicht erkennt das Spiel das ist halt so round-robin jeder darf mal für ein halbes Jahr US-Präsident sein.
Deswegen ist jetzt turnusgemäß Österreich in dieser Rolle und außerdem hat man so auf den Eindruck dass
der ganze oppositions Bereich der nun wirklich stark gefordert wäre eigentlich in diesen Zeiten komplett auseinander schmilzt und wie ist es doch gerade der Chef der SPÖ
zurückgetreten und bei der anderen sieht auch nicht besser aus kannst du das noch mal ein bis zusammenfassen was da eigentlich gerade los.
Ich ich wollte hier noch mal irgendwie kurz berichten wie die generelle politische Lage in Österreich so ist tagespolitische werden
Christian Kern der Chef der SPÖ ist diese Woche wenn es am Donnerstag auf und er ist zurückgetreten
ACAB skurrile Art und Weise eigentlich eine gute Frage.
Dem Impfen ja.
Warum war schon eine gute Frage
also ihr seid in Österreich echt nichts mehr gewohnt als Dual ist hier die höchste Weiden bekommt hat mama warum fragt ihr Sohn hat dürfen Sie jetzt hier nicht Vorgehen gegen Politiker
der passt doch mal auf den Herrn Lohninger auf das Verhör.
Ja wir mögen gerne über andere aber selber sind die ganze Zeit hatte ich nicht
nein das offizielle Grund ist dass er nach Brüssel gehen will dass er Spitzenkandidat für die europäische Sozialdemokratie werden will und der neue Kommissionspräsident werden will wie erinnern uns sein
der letzten Europawahl ist es so dass die europäischen Parteien Familien ein Spitzenkandidat aufstellen und wenn die Sozialdemokraten die Mehrheit bekommen würden dann ist der nächste Kommissionspräsident der Spitzenkandidat der Sozialdemokraten
so ist Jean-Claude Juncker ins Amt gekommen und hat sich gegen
Bach wie hieß er noch mal Mister 100% Schulz in Bad stand durchgesetzt und dass wir Christian Kern jetzt auch werden was schon irgendwie Mittel unrealistisch ist weil.
Also Yoga hat sich nicht als hätte Sozialdemokraten durchgesetzt sondern.
So an die Konservativen hatten mehr Stimmen als die Sozialdemokraten insgesamt im Europaparlament und so wurde Juncker Kommissionspräsident und Schulz hat eine andere laufbar genommen wie wir wissen.
Ja aber gern sagt eben er will nach Brüssel das ist nur irgendwie nicht recht glaubwürdig weil wir haben mit Manfred Weber
den dem deutschen Politiker der sich auch vor einigen Wochen angekündigt hat als Spitzenkandidat für die Konservativen schon einen deutschsprachigen Spitzenkandidaten im Rennen der recht gute Chancen hat.
Klammer auf CSU Klammer.
Anders wäre irgendwie recht unüblich dass man zwei deutsche Spitzenkandidatin hat also die sollten deutschsprachigen Spitzenkandidaten hat also wenn man da nicht irgendwie wenigstens französisch und oder Spanisch spricht
ist es schon irgendwie schwierig und natürlich kann Christian Kern Spitzenkandidat der österreichischen SPÖ werden wenn die dann in die Europawahl einzieht.
Dazu braucht eigentlich auch an Parteitagsbeschluss und oder sonst irgendwie eine Listen Erstellung und das wird man nicht nur so Überacker mazion.
Was wirklich passiert ist wissen wie etwas Medienberichten ist dass es irgendwie so ein Abendessen gab wofür Leute waren alles SPÖ Kranken und da hat Kern gesagt ich will nicht mehr.
An das mit der Opposition kann ich nicht ich bin ja eigentlich als Bahnmanager hier reingegangen um Bundeskanzler zu werden Christian Kern war Manager bei der
ÖBB bei der Österreichischen Bundesbahn und da eigentlich sehr erfolgreich auch in der flüchtlingskrise irgendwie schon der Kampagne gemacht mit Menschenrechte fahren mit bei uns und war irgendwie so gehypt als der Messias der.
Bekennt das Bild vielleicht und hatte einen sehr verhassten Vorgänger Werner Faymann abgelöst in der Rolle als Spitzenkandidat und ist sofort Bundeskanzler geworden er hatte sich nicht eine Wahl zu stellen sondern.
Werte laufen Regierung einfach den Chef,
Chef abgelöst und dann aber recht bald danach war diese Regierung hat auch vorbei und jetzt haben wir Sebastian Kurz als Regierungschef und Christian Kern hat immer gesagt nein er bleibt 10 Jahre in der.
Kunde geht in die Opposition und er führt die SPÖ wieder zum Kanzler vor einer Woche hat er noch gesagt diese Gerüchte dass ich nach Brüssel gehen will zum total am Mund,
und ich habe auf jeden Fall vor in Österreich da da da da da altes wurde widerlegt
als er sich jetzt dann sehr überraschend
Einrichtung Busse verabschiedet hat was sich nicht widerlegt hat ist das Gerücht was auch im Raum stand das Christian Kern eigentlich zu Gazprom gehen wollte oder einfach zurück in die Wirtschaft weil das mit der Politik ihm doch nicht zu liegt.
Ja auf jeden Fall ist der SPÖ jetzt ihr Chef abhanden gekommen und es gibt keinen Nachfolger die Creme an haben sich Zeit genommen bis Mitte Oktober da einen Nachfolger zu besetzen das heißt es gibt jetzt fast ein Monat lang eine.
Ein Interregnum eine Vakanz an einer ganz wichtigen Stelle und das mitten
in der Gesagten Ratspräsidentschaft ist die SPÖ komplett führerlos und und der jetzige Spitzenkandidat bisherige Spitzenkandidat und Chef ist da jetzt einfach mal extrem bestätigt auch
und würde sich sicherlich schwer tun die Regierung zu kritisieren obwohl es das ja für kritikfähige SG.
GSP ist die größte Oppositionspartei hat als zweitstärkste Kraft die letzte Nationalratswahl 2017.
Eigentlich noch recht gut angeschlagen ja und wer ist sonst noch in der Opposition müsste man sich jetzt eigentlich mal fragen es gibt noch dieten
wird stärkste Kraft in Österreich national sind die Neos die liberale Partei stehen für das neue Österreich und.
Hatten einen sehr charismatischen Chef Matthias Strolz der diese Partei wirklich auch rhetorisch sehr gut und inhaltlich gut geführt hat über viele Jahre und sich.
Ja genau.
Der Remixer Bilder.
Pater razelli hatte seine Freude mit ich und das zurecht wir müssen ja racette verlinken auf jeden.
Ja auf jeden Fall.
Und arrr mit Matthias Strolz war immer irgendwie so er war früher Rhetoriktrainer lustigerweise Sebastian Kurz bar.
Training bei Matthias Strolz die die die Liberalen in Österreich sind irgendwie so aus dem konservativen entstanden die waren.
Der schöne Witz war damals immer die Neos sind der schulfilter ÖVP dass ich einfach mal abgespalten hat.
Und
auf jeden Fall ist da Matthias Strolz derjenige gewesen der wirklich sehr eloquent das in Österreich sehr wichtige bildungsthema vorangetrieben hat und der insgesamt.
Du hast austeilen konnte wenn's um
politische Missstände gegen A&R hat sich muss man sagen eigentlich am Höchstpunkt seiner Karriere zurückgezogen hat.
NAMM 2018 eben als die Regierung schon im Amt war gesagt na ich habe jetzt eigentlich diese Partei aufgestellt ich habe sie gegründet ich habe sie
ah jetzt durch 2 Fallen gebracht was was ist ja hohe Hürden waren in Österreich überhaupt mit einer neuen
Hi anzutreten und jetzt drücke ich schon in Folge ins Parlament zu bringen geschaffen die wenigsten
und er hat all das geschafft und sagt jetzt ok jetzt verabschiede ich mich ich habe mein Werk erfülltes von jetzt an der weitermachen die Nachfolgerin Beate meinl-reisinger kennt man aus der Wiener Landespolitik hat die Niers auch mitbegründet aber muss sich halt erst noch etwa polieren.
Da ist auf jeden Fall mal jemand abhandengekommen dir auch ein sehr guter Politiker war und sehr gut in der Kritik der Regierung,
gut dann haben wir noch die letzte Oppositionspartei.
Also guter Politiker im Sinne von Themen ja angesprochen hat wie er aufgetreten ist ist er hat ja jetzt nicht wirklich ein Amt übernommen derzeit.
Genau genau Politiker im Sinne von.
Bundesamt Urlaub ein Staatsamt zu.
Er war immer er war Abgeordneter insofern war Politiker und der war Clubchef von der war eben auch der figurehead.
Partei aber er hat sich nicht in der Hinsicht hat das nie in ein Amt geschafft hatten Regierungsbeteiligung.
Ja dann die letzte Oppositionspartei die wir noch haben ist die Liste Pilz.
Stefan schon mal im Podcast über geredet die Grünen haben es nicht mehr rein geschafft nach fast 25 Jahren seit lange Zeit wo die Grünen wirkt,
die ungemütliche Oppositionspartei waren die ich auch wirklich so
vielen Dingen Themen ins Parlament kam kologie auf die Agenda gesetzt hat haben sie die Grünen eben nicht mehr rein geschafft stattdessen gibt es die Liste Pilz die aber.
Aufgrund der bereden rund um Ihren.
Namens Begründer Peter Pilz auch sehr angeschlagen ist Peter Pilz hat es geschafft seine Partei ins Parlament zu bringen über die die 4% Hürde und
ist dann aber selber nicht ins Parlament gegangen weil es einen wird bei Governor in den USA Anschuldigungen gab das von von 6 vermisst Kanada zu sexuellen Übergriffen
die dazu geführt haben dass er gemeint hat ich melde mich jetzt mal meinen eigenen Zahn dazu und nehme mein Mandat nicht an das heißt die Liste Pilz ist ohne Peter Pilz.
Ins Parlament eingezogen die sind ein sehr gemischtes Team da gibt's einige sehr
gute Leute und einiges sehr zweifelhafte Leute in den Club und,
Bild war sozusagen irgendwie im Hintergrund und hat gefehlt er hatte sie jetzt dann riding Personalrochaden und dem Ausschluss einer freien Abgeordneten Martha bißmann aus dem Klub geschafft wieder
reinzukommen und hat jetzt sein Mandat sitzt doch im BVT Untersuchungsausschuss.
Hat aber leider eine viel kompetente Politikerin Alma zadic rausgeworfen dafür auf jeden Fall ist peterpilz.at wieder da
aber seine Partei ist auch auf jeden Fall ja.
Ich weiß jetzt dass jetzt erwähnt ich vermiss gerade Information er hat die Grünen mal mit gegründet aber warum ist er denn dort rausgegangen.
Weil da gibt's auch wiederum mehrere geschichtserzählungen die auf der Teller Geschichte ist weil die Grünen irgendwie so
schwierig wurden irgendwie zu feministisch zu Links nicht sich nicht trauten AAA offen über die Probleme im politischen Islam zu sprechen Zitat Ende
und das heißt da ist auf jeden Fall auch eine,
gewisse inhaltliche Differenzierung die die stattgefunden hat aber dann noch ein gewisses geschmeckt wäre bloß dass die Grünen auch ohne Peter Pilz schon in Problemen waren weil da mehrere Skandale waren mit
Rauswurf ihrer Jugendorganisation die Jungen Grünen heißt wie ich finde aus berechtigten Gründen weil die wirklich irgendwie.
Inhaltsleer aufgetreten sind
A und Rebellion gemacht haben und vielen anderen Skandalen eigentlich auch noch die die Grünen insgesamt schon angeschlagen haben dann hat Peter Pilz das ist die offizielle Begründung den Listenplatz nicht bekommen den er eigentlich wollte als er hätte glaube ich auf,
vier kandidieren wollen und sie haben Sex gegeben oder wollte Sex unter der 8 bekommen alle sichere Listenplätze aber.
Anhand dessen dass er,
in diesen Listen erstellungs Verfahren was bei den Grünen basisdemokratisch passiert oder auch nicht ausgewählt werden konnte vorher als hat genau diesen einen Platz in der haben wollte nicht bekommen hat.
Ist ja nicht mehr angetreten
und hat dann daraufhin seine eigene Partei gegründet was glaube ich recht gut inszeniert war aber schon länger geplant weil seine Partei zu gründen ist recht viel Arbeit auf jeden Fall
wir haben irgendwie eine Sozialdemokratie die sich sowieso schon mit Netzpolitik schwertut jetzt in der Opposition hatte viel besser als als sie noch an die Regierung war wir haben eine liberale Partei die eigentlich gut war Bürgerrechten ist aber jetzt auch irgendwie.
Arm mit einer neuen Person wieder noch mal eine starke Oppositionsrolle braucht und wir haben irgendwie Kühne und pilz.de,
komischer rumturnen und wo man jetzt auch noch drauf wartet wie du schlagkräftig Design werden und vor diesem Hintergrund würde ich sagen.
Die Region kann eigentlich durchregieren.
Da gibt's wenig Widerstand da gibt's wenig wo sie wirklich mit massiver Kritik oder vereinbar charismatisch geäußert hatte
hinter der sich die Geister sammeln können rechnen muss an das ist eine sehr schwierige Ausgangslage wenn wenn staatliche Kraft nicht mit checks and balances rechnen muss.
Was man hier auch sieht ist das die
österreichische Politik wirklich zum weglaufen ist wirklich auch den Spitzen der Oppositionsparteien scheinbar reicht nach einiger Zeit und die sich denken vielleicht mache ich doch lieber was anderes
M&S für schon in gewisser Weise auch auf dem politischen Diskurs zurück dass man einfach.
Mit Kritik nicht durchkommt dass der Parlamentarismus fehlt und und und und man auch mal irgendwie wenigstens das Kopieren von guten Ideen nicht passiert sondern alles nur im Hintergrund ausgewaschen
wird aber das auf jeden Fall ein Problem
was wir in Österreich haben und es wird sehr spannend zu beobachten ich glaube Zivilgesellschaft ist deshalb umso wichtiger
eine braucht diese kritischen Stimmen weil die Regierung halt einfach im Moment.
Mit sehr viel Gestaltungswillen und sehr viel Macht ausgestattet noch vier Jahre Zeit hat ihre Agenda durchzusetzen.
Also im Prinzip auch ein ähnliches Bild nicht wahr also wir haben so eine links geprägte Opposition die sich nicht grün ist das was des Wortes und so ein bisschen in den eigenen Beschäftigung vergeht ohne sich wirklich gegen den politischen Gegner ordentlich aufzustellen die in diesem Defizit sich auch noch die größten lapsi
leisten kann und einfach durch marschiert ist es am Ende dann auch nicht so sehr viel anders als als.
Ich frag mich ob das in Deutschland anders Wer will wird werden zB Nissan Urheberrechts Beispiel machen das mal fest wir haben wirklich seit 2016 nur getrommelt
ging dieses Gesetz und gegen upload-filter und wirklich viele Diskussionsveranstaltungen gemacht die ÖVP fehlte bei jeder
Island die haben einfach Diskussions Verweigerung betrieben es ist leichter irgendwie die FPÖ auf solche eines zu bekommen und und und ihre Position zu erfragen als.
Das Wetter über Peter Fall ist und dann aber er gibt's doch wieder so Veranstaltungen wo die ÖVP zum Thema einlädt.
Wo war dann irgendwie sogar Axel Voss und Medi Ministerrat Blümel hat und die diskutieren das dann aber nur noch ihrem eigenen Drehbuch.
Also es geht wenn sich die Konservativen auf Debatten einlassen dann nur unter einer extremen message control aber nicht in einem öffentlichen Setup
und das ist auch glaube ich sehr bezeichnend für die Art wie wie Demokratie eben nicht funktioniert wenn es immer nur das.
Ja um noch vielleicht ein letztes Mal die EU Perspektive noch mal rein zu bekommen was wird aus dieser Ratspräsidentschaft welche Prioritäten verfolgt.
Der Kanzler Herr kurz.
Also das größte Thema aber die größte Herausforderung für ihn ist definitiv brexit.
Wetter dass schafft irgendwie hier an sinnvollen Thiel hinzubekommen das wäre schon eine Meisterleistung
da kann man ja im Grunde auch noch moderierend auf den Rat einwirken das Parlament und die Briten haben dann natürlich ihre eigene Meinungsbildung aber das ist auf jeden Fall das wichtigste Thema.
Ist das jetzt ist das wichtigste Thema für ihn.
Weil er jetzt quasi als Ratspräsident ja hier weil das Eier also bald ein Licht hat sich das große Thema sein sollte oder hat er da irgendwie es hat irgendwie auch noch mal auf eine besondere Art und Weise investiert.
Er hatte keinerlei Positionierung die abweicht von dem generellen Kurs dient die EU jaja unisono hat also ein Verein es ist ja hier er Tusk und G Verhofstadt
die Führer der US-Präsident und und und Parov Stelar Manchester Vertreter des Parlaments die ja an sich schon STR gerade Linie fahren.
Und es gibt genau exakt und dadurch haben wir hier glaube ich auch nicht viel Spielraum aber die rad Residenz haftendes in gewisser Weise ja eine.
Moderierende Rolle die didi28 bei 27 Staats und Regierungschefs auf eine Linie zu bringen und da eigentlich sehr viel Verhandlung und Diplomatie
um um diese Einigung zu erzielen und die dann aber durchaus in Trilux z.b. durchzusetzen und da hat zu verhandeln und und sozusagen auf die eigene getroffene Position.
Zu setzen und die durchzubringen II Thema wo wir das sicherlich weiter aus ihrem gehen wird es das ganze Flüchtlings in Sicherheits Thema.
Aber mal kurz interessiert mich natürlich brennend jetzt ja mit dem mit dem brexit also du meinst er verfolgt hier überhaupt gar keine eigene Strategie sondern also was ist denn dann sozusagen seine Rolle der Zeit.
Eine gute Frage also ich weiß das bei dem
EU-Staaten Regierungs Gipfel der jetzt gerade noch in Salzburg stattfindet dieses Thema das prominenteste ist
was sie verhandeln werden.
Gibt es viele Aussagen von ihm aber das sind hauptsächlich Sprechblasen ich hätte jetzt keine österreichische Linie bei diesem Thema gesehen vielleicht ist es einfach nur der Kelch an ihm jetzt diese Position möglichst eloquent gegenüber.
EU Bevölkerung und den Briten zu kommunizieren ich kann mir aber schon vorstellen dass es hinter den Kulissen wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
Behandlungen gibt in Sachen Irland die dann vielleicht doch eher im Rat passieren als in anderen Gremien nur über die hätte ich jetzt doch nichts gehört.
Da vielleicht die einzelnen Positionierungen der Länder sind aber da sie ich am erstens noch am Spielraum wo wo die Ratspräsidentschaft
gemeint ist aber der resetten Roller wichtige Rolle spielen okay aber Sicherheit als also Sebastian Kurz.
Schreib dich immer auf die Fahnen er hat die Balkanroute geschlossen er ist der Messias weil er hat den Flüchtlingsheim.
Flüchtlingsstrom gestoppt und das will er jetzt auch mit der Mittelmeerroute machen und da gibt's ja auch jetzt die Diskussion von Anhalt die Zentren in in in Afrika ich glaub das ist ein Thema das war in Deutschland sehr bekannt ist.
Das ist sicherlich auch mache ich jetzt mal.
Die zwei wichtigsten Sache die er sich auf die Fahnen schreibt aber wenn man seine Rede zum Antritt gehört hat er war am 3. Juli im Europaparlament in der Angelobung sozusagen als Ratspräsident und hat dort
drei Themen genannt das wahre Leben Sicherheit Migration Erregers hebe und eben Digitalisierung und ich glaube gerade da werden wir auch,
in D-Netz politischen Dossiers einen Fokus sehen dass Österreich besonders intensiv verhandeln wird um die Uhr berechtigt Erinnern fertigzustellen.
Da liegen ihnen auch die Verleger in Österreich massiv in den Ohren das werden sie versuchen wenn sie können bei der Anti Terror Verordnung
jetzt eben vorgestellt wurde errechne ich auch damit es ist der Reich hier ist sehr massiv nach vorne drücken wird und versuchen words
dieses Gesetz noch unter der eigenen Ratspräsidentschaft durch zu verhandeln das muss auch schon fast irgendwie jetzt bis Ende des Jahres braucht es mindestens eine Radposition wenn ich sogar schon ein Kilo gekrümelt damit sich das noch irgendwie ausgeht das letzte
felinum im Europaparlament ist im April 2019 also ansonsten wird es knapp.
Am und dann gibt's noch andere Sachen die.
E-privacy-verordnung ist etwas wo wir uns wünschen würden dass es auf dass es um schneller weiter geht da hat das Parlament schon lange seine.
Position gefunden e-privacy-verordnung wir erinnern uns vielleicht ist eingesetzt dass nach der datenschutz-grundverordnung gekommen ist und da geht sozusagen um das Briefgeheimnis online da geht es um das tracking.
Also was dürfen Webseiten mit meinen Daten machen wir können alle diese idiotischen cookie-banner wo wir pawlowsche Hunde trainiert werden einfach nur weg weg weg zu kriegen in Wirklichkeit gehörte ein ja nein oder Seite verlassen.
Und da sind auch so Team drin wie offline Tracking ob man mit den eigenen Telefon wenn man sich durch,
haben Einzelhandelskauffrau Häuser bewegt gecheckt werden darf und dann personalisierte Werbung angezeigt werden darf oder auch ob mein Mobilfunk Provider meine
Location Daten auswerten und verkaufen dafür sind sehr wichtiges Gesetz das weitaus mehr regelt als nur die datenschutzgrundverordnung
und das Brot gerade über die Klippe der Wahrheit zufallen wenn Österreich hier nicht schnell eine Position für den Rat etabliert.
Und wir drücken da massiv auf die Tube das Österreich das endlich mal tut und die wollten zuerst wirklich
im im Juli haben sind Vorschlag vor geliefert und erst im Dezember wollten sie wieder etwas dazu machen jetzt wird wieder verhandelt und hoffentlich gibt's da bald eine Einigung damit dieses Gesetz noch vor der Wahl
im Europaparlament beschlossen wird weil ansonsten droht das auch komplett über zufallen und.
Das ist ein richtiges Ding und was ich auch noch an denen Willis TIR wird deins das ist ein anderes Gesetz wo es.
Wir haben das mal kurz erwähnt im Podcast wurde um den Zugriff auf Daten von Hostern geht
wenn das so kommt wie die Kommission es sich vorstellt dann kann eine polnische Polizeibehörde.
Für irgendwelche Verbrechen die in Polen.
Stapler sind aber in Deutschland oder Österreich gar keine Straftaten sind zu deutschen Unternehmen gehen und sagen gib mir mal die Daten von diesem User.
Ohne dass irgendein Beamter in Deutschland irgend ein Richter irgendein Staatsanwalt da involviert ist das heißt das was wir heute haben ist.
Inge.
In einem Staat illegal sind müssen im anderen auch illegal sein und dann gibt es Rechtshilfeersuchen das dauert lange dass wir das mühsam bezeichnet dass das so viel Reibungsverlust ist man könnte noch Rechtsschutz dazu sagen und das soll abgeschafft werden.
Also im analogen wäre das so wie wenn die ungarische Polizei nach Österreich kommt für eine Hausdurchsuchung.
Das wäre analog undenkbar aber im digitalen ist es denkbar und deswegen steht in diesem Gesetz das verharrt noch so im Parlament
und im Rat ist aber auch eines der wichtigen digital Themen die wahrscheinlich unter der österreichischen Ratspräsidentschaft noch diskutiert und vielleicht auch fertig verhandelt.
Wie gelingt es uns jetzt hier noch einen eleganten Ausklang zu machen.
Ich kann noch einen Schemel selber probieren das Bad hätte.
Damit Alters nicht kommt ihr habt schon erwähnt wir suchen hatte neue Leute bei epicenter works oder wenn ihr mit helfen wolltest es nicht so schlimm kommt wie es gerade dargestellt
bewerbt euch bei uns ist wahrscheinlich einer der Spanne daran Jobs in der Netzpolitik man muss dafür leider in Wien wohnen weil wir hier unser Büro haben aber,
wir suchen gerade jemanden der uns in der Kommunikation unterstützt also vor allem netzpolitische Kampanien.
Sich mit uns ausdenkt durchführt wirklich jemanden der praktisch Hand anlegt.
Damit der Vergangenheit zu viel auf Straßen gemacht und viel Bilder erzeugt wir wollen auch mehr online campaigning machen auch Webentwickler Programmierer die an puls bauen wollen über die sich dann.
Halbe Million Menschen wieder in Europa
für ne Zentralität einsetzt solche Leute suchen wir und da geht's halt ganz stark um auch das Entwickeln von
Lösungen oder von zumindest Werkzeugen die Menschen nutzen können und Teil der Lösung zu werden dass ich mich so Funktion für formulieren und Praktikanten suchen wir auch.
Anversich verkatert erstellen qualifiziert für die können Spenden dann haben wir vielleicht auch dann habe ich vielleicht doch irgendwie wieder mehr als die Hälfte meiner Zeit übrig für Themen bei dem Moment ist die Hälfte meiner Zeit Fundraising.
An neben einem anderen damit wir uns da diese Stelle noch leisten.
Da werden helle letzte Woche schon mal drauf hingewiesen und ja im Prinzip.
Steht dir ja Entscheidung noch aus also wer von euch Lust hat als Communications Manager in Wien aktiv zu werden kann
Bypässe da da finde ich werden aber auch Entwicklerin sind gefragt und.
Das Praktikum dreht sich um juristisches Praktikum Barcelona.
Ja wobei ist es inzwischen so schwer gute Webentwickler zu finden weil Leute wirklich ja krackhardt haben die nämlich auch so einfach das kriege ich schon irgendwie also.
Ungesehen.
Ja ja.
Und für die Stelle muss man gar nicht in Österreich sein also für die Entwickler Geschichte kann die Leute sogar sitzen wo sie wollen natürlich also in Deutschland wäre sogar vorteilhaft in dem Fall.
Gut und das denke ich mal bringt uns jetzt zu den Terminen.
So und weil dieser Sendung sich sowieso fast alles um Thomas drehte sind die Termine diesmal deine Reisetermine wenn ich das richtig sehe für dich der nächste Weg morgen nach Berlin auch wenn wir ich jetzt noch aus der Ferne Quatsch.
Ganz genau netzpolitik.org feiert seinen 14 Geburtstag in Berlin an der gibt's wieder eine tolle Konferenz und danach eine noch viel toller reparti und wer in Berlin ist am 21 September sollte dort vorbeischauen.
Dann steigst du wieder ins Flugzeug oder fährst mit dem Zug ich weiß es nicht auf jeden Fall geht nach Brüssel und auch da wartet schon die nächste Veranstaltung des freedom not fear backen.
Wer das nicht kennt freedom noch 4 ist nach der edry Generalversammlung wahrscheinlich die zweit höchste Dichte an Netz politischen AktivistInnen und wirklichen tolles Barcamp um sich zu,
vernetzen mit wirklich allen Leuten von ganz Europa und da schaut da hin wenn ihr einfach so satt.
Das ist an diesem Wochenende genau also fängt auch am 21.09 schon an und geht bis zum 24.9.
Und weißt dann schon langsam kalt wird es zieht sich in den Süden nach Lissabon zum Open Source lisb'on und das ist was.
Das ist eine Konferenz wo ich selber noch nicht wahr aber Lissabon Portugal ist der.
Rupie der Netzneutralität und ich würde da eingeladen um mich mit der Telekom Industrie zu streiten was ich liebend gerne tue an falls wir hören oder nicht politisch interessierte Menschen in Portugal haben es wird mich freuen Euch kennenzulernen.
Zeig mir doch.
Der ganze am27 September also in einer Woche ja das bringt das ans Ende der Sendung wieder so ein langes Ding geworden.
Ja ich hoffe es war nicht zu pessimistisch das.
Ich glaube nicht dass die Leute hier unbedingt wegen des Optimismus einschalten sondern Regisseur um die Realität zu verarbeiten.
Dazu helfen Fakten Fakten Fakten Fakten immer an hörading
ja Thomas vielen Dank wir sehen uns dann morgen wie schon erwähnt netzpolitik.org dass es ja hat sich jetzt ganz gut eingependelt das ist ja jetzt das
fünfte Mal dass das stattfindet und ist in zunehmendem Maße auch sodass
habe sondern das sage ich will das jetzt nicht überhöhen aber dort kommen dann doch schon eine ganze Menge Leute zusammen
die Ding Gesamtnetz politischen Aktivismus im europäischen Bereich gut mitgestalten und teilweise repräsentieren insofern
guter Ort um da zusammenzukommen auch Feierabend immer ordentlich gefeiert wird.
Jantes das Programm ist dieses Jahr wirklich exzellent also die haben Züge geschafft da alle relevanten Themen auf der Agenda zu haben und auch die die richtigen Leute dazu haben Julia Rede wird auch ein Vortrag halten
und wenn wenn ihr irgendwie in der gegenseitig Cup
Tickets sind jetzt auch nicht so teuer ist ansich Euro oder so da kann man auf jeden Fall vorbeischauen.
Machst du auch ein Vortrag.
Ich habe einen Tag Shop ich bereits nicht mehr so viel Vorträge ich mache Workshops das ist weniger Vorbereitung und man kann die anderen Leute auch reden lassen.
Das finde ich sehr löblich sowas mache ich ja auch immer
ride dann machen wir hier mal den Deckel drauf vielen Dank Thomas vielen Dank an euch alle die ihr uns so fleißig unterstützt und bis zum Ende zuhört.
Wir sagen tschüss nächste Woche dann vielleicht auch mit mehr Fallout von der Netzpolitik Konferenz das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen und was da sonst noch so andere Shitstorms der Realität auf uns nieder regnet
wir spannen für euch den Schirm auf und bis dahin sei mal Tschüss bis bald.